franz um korrespondenten und reporter im
bundestag erhard scherfer
ja vielen dank stephan kohler einzelplan
09 so heißt das werk das hier ab 9 uhr
diskutiert wird zum ersten mal seit den
gründerjahren neuen titel klima
wirtschaft und klimaschutz das war
bislang noch nicht in einem haushalt
vereinigt und auch schon gar nicht in
einem ressort und wir haben es in diesen
tagen natürlich damit zu tun dass wenn
man über dieses ministerium redet und
über dieses ministerium diskutiert und
über seinen etat spielen natürlich
energie das thema energie
energiesicherheit bezahlbare energie
eine große rolle und dann sind wir auch
schon wieder bei dem thema dieser nacht
und beim koalitionsausschuss der ja um
11 uhr seine ergebnisse bekanntgeben
will wir sind gespannt wie das ganze
ausgegangen ist wir werden das thema
energie und energiesicherheit aber auch
jetzt schon besprechen und ich freue
mich dass bei uns sind heute morgen
franziska brantner parlamentarische
staatssekretärin beim bundesminister für
wirtschaft und klimaschutz guten morgen
ihn und alexander dobrindt ist da erster
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion und natürlich auch
vorsitzender der csu landesgruppe auch
einen schönen guten morgen guten morgen
frau brandner was können sie uns schon
sagen zu dem was wir um 11 uhr dann auch
offiziell erfahren zumindest die
richtung natürlich wissen wir die
fraktionsspitzen werden sich die
ergebnisverkündung vorbehalten aber
können sie zumindest eine ahnung geben
in welche richtung es gehen könnte wir
haben ein entlastungspaket für
bürgerinnen und bürger als die
verbraucher und die unternehmen
und das ist glaube ich auch richtig und
gut so die details werden um 11 uhr
vorgestellt bitte verzeihen sie mir dass
ich die jetzt noch nicht nennen kann
aber ich glaube wir sind auf einem guten
weg hier die bedürfnisse zu sehen
zielgerichtete und gute antworten zu
finden womit rechnen sie ja dobrindt
dass man sagen dass er ein absolut
singulärer vorgaben sind grad in den
haushaltsberatungen das heißt vorgestern
hat der finanzminister den haushalt
eingebracht gestern hat der
bundeskanzler den haushalt begründet und
heute nacht sind offensichtlich
entscheidungen getroffen worden die
erheblichste auswirkung auf den haushalt
haben und es bisher nichts bekannt ein
sehr seltsames vorgehen man könnte auch
sagen ein respektloses vorgehen
gegenüber dem deutschen bundestag
passiert
das hier verhandelt wird über einen
haushalt währenddessen die regierung
entscheidungen trifft die vollkommen
unbekannt sind und in diesen
haushaltsdebatten doch keine rolle
spielen können nicht mehr sagen
vorbereiten wahrscheinlich wollten sie
das eben auch schon andeuten wird das
natürlich auch noch im parlament
behandelt werden natürlich es ist ein
ergänzungs haushalt der der aktuellen
situation geschuldet ist dass wir in
europa einen krieg haben mit natürlich
auch massiven auswirkungen auf unser
land und es wäre ja verantwortungslos
wenn wir das ignorieren würden die cdu
selber hat ja nach auch entlastungen
gerufen wir haben jetzt ein gutes paket
geschnürt natürlich wird das auch durch
den bundestag gehen als ergänzungs
haushalt ist es ja klar aber wir müssen
in der situation reagieren das ist so
alles andere wäre verantwortungslos
kommen wir mal an voll gewesen wenn man
vor einigen tagen eine entscheidung
getroffen wird in der bundesregierung
wir haben die auch angemahnt haben die
entlastungen eingefordert die
energiepreise sind nicht seit gestern
explodiert und gestiegen sondern sein
doch unsere fans uns runter hätte man da
hätte man rechtzeitig natürlich handeln
können jetzt sagen sie ein guter
kompromiss wir kennen den kompromiss
nicht sie können auch nicht vorstellen
also wir wissen nicht über gut ist ich
habe erhebliche zweifel
weil wenn der debatte gestern und
vorgestern ja gesehen haben wie
unterschiedlich zwischen den grünen der
spd und der fdp die interessen da
verteilt war wir haben einen vorschlag
gemacht haben gesagt entlastung bei der
steuer bei der energie steuer bei der
mehrwertsteuer wir sind sehr gespannt ob
die bundesregierung diesen maßnahmen
nachkommt so wie wir vorgeschlagen haben
jetzt kommen nämlich beide ganze
erwartungsvoll an gegen die ich war ein
bisschen irritiert weil sie gerade auch
einfach schon mal geantwortet haben
bevor ich was gefragt habe aber
wesentliche zurück im regulären
verfahren da freue ich mich frau brands
debatte dass hier noch nicht im das ist
ein interview
wie sicher ist die energieversorgung im
moment in deutschland die
energieversorgung ist sicher die ist
wirklich gesichert wir haben seit januar
angefangen auch wieder die sogenannten
long term auction für gas zu nutzen das
sind optionen die wir haben
um die gas bestände auch zu erhöhen das
haben wir schon vor dem krieg gemacht
das heißt wir sind da absolut jetzt auf
einem guten weg und richtungen herbst
und winter da kennen sie ja da sind wir
intensiv nicht nur international dabei
sondern auch bei uns mit einem paket was
jetzt kommen wird oster paket sommer
paket um bei uns auch effizienzen zu
vergrößern in die erneuerbaren zu gehen
grünen wasserstoff voranzubringen wir
gehen jetzt wirklich in die vollen um
von dieser energieabhängigkeit von
russland auch loszukommen das ist das
gebot der stunde wir sehen dass die
energieabhängigkeit einen sehr hohen
preis hat den können wir uns auf dauer
nicht leisten
und deswegen nutzen wir jetzt wirklich
auch diesen haushalt um nochmal schritt
voranzukommen der parteivorsitzende der
csu ihr parteivorsitzender herr dobrindt
ist anderer ansicht der meint ohne
kernkraft hat er gezögert heute wird es
kalt und teuer im nächsten winter als
brücke braucht ist die kernkraft noch
für mindestens drei jahre es muss
schluss sein mit ausstiegen aller art
der energiepreis wird so zur armutsfalle
und zum standort nachteil das wäre reine
grüne ideologie heizen wir demnächst mit
atomenergie
leider verweigert sich das
wirtschaftsministerium einer
ideologiefreien prüfung der kernenergie
und der möglichkeit des weiterlaufen der
kernkraftwerke wir wissen dass 13
prozent des russischen gas in
deutschland verstromt werden das heißt
es wird daraus strom produziert und wenn
man dann auf der anderen seite sieht
dass wir kernenergie abschalten mit der
wir den strom weiter produzieren können
dann sieht man wir schaffen keine
unabhängigkeit von russischem erdgas
sondern wir halten an diesen
abhängigkeiten leider mehr fest als es
notwendig wäre und deswegen ja es ist
zwingend geboten jetzt die prüfungen
noch mal richtig durchzuführen
ideologiefrei durchzuführen die
kernkraftwerke die dieses jahr noch
laufen weiter laufen zu lassen und
möglicherweise auch die dem letzten jahr
abgeschaltet worden sind wieder ans netz
gehen zu lassen das wäre zwingend
geboten jetzt als maßnahme um
unabhängiger wert zu werden von den
russischen importen habe ich trotzdem
noch mal eine technische frage die alle
busse die größte anteil was er über gas
angeht wird tatsächlich für fürs heizen
verwendet geht den gasheizungen
beispielsweise rein da kommen sie mit
atomkraft nicht voran das steht was
können sehen ja tauschen das stimmt das
geht aber auch nur schritt für schritt
wir haben das immer deutlich gesagt ist
ein sofortiges abschalten des zufuhren
der energie aus russland halten wir für
nicht möglich es kann uns allerdings das
ist ja offen von der anderen seite
drohen wir sehen ja dass putin auch
weitere maßnahmen gerade wenn es um das
bezahlen geht jetzt mit rubel einsetzt
um es schwieriger zu machen und deswegen
ist die bundesregierung ja auch
aufgefordert und dabei maßnahmen zu
ergreifen wie man diese unabhängigkeit
am schluss und darstellen kann ob
einzelne elemente daraus dann von
unserer seite gegriffen werden können
ist nach wie vor offen aber es braucht
elemente um unabhängiger zu werden die
kernenergie wäre eines dieser also wir
halten die in dieser pauschalität ist es
offensichtlich nicht umzusetzen wie es
von markus söder getwittert wurde frau
brandt
mit atomkraft kann man nicht die
gasheizungen ersetzen es ist einfach
nicht möglich das ist aber was herr
söder gesagt hat das ist offensichtlich
falsch wir haben das sehr intensiv
geprüft und
ergebnis gekommen dass es die probleme
die wir haben nicht löst aber extrem
hohe kosten verursachen würde weil wenn
sie weiterlaufen brauchen die
atomkraftwerke eine neue
sicherheitsüberprüfung und ich bin mir
sicher dass auch sie sie nicht ohne eine
neue sicherheits überprüfung
weiterlaufen lassen würden warum es
schwierig meine medien
groß die gefahren aber trotzdem geht es
auch unsere sicherheit
sicherheiten von es geht darum dass wir
schauen was sind unsere genauen probleme
die haben wir beim heizen und wie gehen
wir damit um wir haben die übrigens auch
in der industrie dort hilft es auch
nicht dass heißt wir haben konkrete
probleme mit der gar mit dem gas
deswegen können wir auch nicht sofort
auf null gehen mit russischem gas und
wir suchen nach antworten
sie müssen diesen haufen die antworten
und im verhältnis stehen zu den kosten
die sie dann
auch erfordern und bei der atomkraft
sehen wir dass mit blick auf die
sicherheit sehr sehr hohe zusätzliche
investitionen nötig wären die sind
wirklich sehr groß und ich bin nicht
bereit die sicherheit unserer
bevölkerung durch ungesicherte
atomkraftwerke zu riskieren dass
würden sie ihn aus und macht eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung und die werden
wir deswegen
auf andere wege gehen sie haben gesagt
die verstromung das wird über kohle
stattfinden das ist auch in unserem
grünen interesse kann man sagen es
genauso schwierig für uns aber es ist
der effizientere und bessere weg und
wenn sie mir erlauben ich finde es
wichtig dass wir in deutschland auch
darüber nachdenken wo wir energie
einsparen können wir haben von der
internationalen energieagentur zwischen
klare empfehlung bekommen welche wege
aller helfen beim sowohl im privaten
aber auch im verkehr als auch in der
industrie da müssen wir jetzt auch an
diese effizienzen zu geben dafür könnte
übrigens auch noch extra gelder das ist
teil des entlastung wäre in der tat eine
meiner nächsten fragen gewesen warum so
wenig über energiesparen und
energieeffizienz in diesen tagen
gesprochen und diskutiert wird aber sie
haben verschiedene einwürfe gemacht eben
als verbrannter geantwortet hat deswegen
wichtige in die gelegenheit geben die
auch noch mal zu formulieren nein ich
habe mich zurückgehalten weil man kann
nicht auf der einen seite diese sehr
ernstzunehmende bedrohung betrachten
wovon nicht davon ausgehen dass die
bundesregierung das auch wirklich tot
und erkennt was der möglicherweise auf
uns zukommt und dann elemente nur weil
sie halt ideologisch unbequemen
diskutieren
die kern gut wir sind versuchen beide
besser zu machen
die kernenergie ist halt nun mal ein
element mit dem man die gas zufuhr aus
russland reduzieren könnte dass er jetzt
nicht alle probleme sagt ja auch keiner
aber es ist ein element wir brauchen
unterschiedlichste bausteine natürlich
ja die kohleverstromung auch die kohle
muss woanders eingekauft werden dass er
ja auch das muss woanders einkaufen
wir haben ja gesehen wie der
bundeswirtschaftsminister einen
hofknicks vor den kataris gemacht hat um
jetzt lg gas einzukaufen
alles das ist notwendig stück für stück
um dafür dann ein ersatz für den
russischen energie zu kriegen aber einig
waren wir sind weil ihre regierung über
jahr uns in eine immer noch größere
abhängigkeit von russland gebracht hat
weil sie nostrum 2 und diese projekte
vorangebracht habe wir sind also dass
wirksamer weil es uns gefällt sondern
weil sie die erneuerbaren gebremst haben
weil sie noch weiter uns in abhängigkeit
von russland gebracht haben wir haben
diese abhängigkeit geerbt weil sie 16
jahre langen falschen polizisten sehr
naiv vor wohl einst gerhard schröder ist
bei der spd und nicht bei der uni kann
sein dass leute die immer hinter dem
friedensdividende die putin zerstört hat
er nicht nur den frieden zerstört er hat
die friedensdividende zerstört wir alle
sind davon ausgegangen dass der handel
mit russland den frieden sichert weil er
wohlstand auf allen seiten schaute die
davon nicht ausgegangen sind und es gab
auch lose reihe die gesagt haben
das grundprinzip frieden durch handel
war gemeingut und ist auch nicht falsch
natürlich ist es richtig dass der
gemeinsame wohlstand den frieden sicher
dass das grundprinzip des aufbaus von
europa dass putin jetzt das gegenteil
tut ist eine ganz bittere erkenntnis auf
die wir entsprechend reagieren müssen
aber jetzt so zu tun als ob in allen
fragen der energieversorgung bis zur
verteidigung die grünen diejenigen
gewesen werden die es ja immer schon
wussten dass wir bei der nato bleiben
müssen dass wir aufrüstung betreiben
müssen dass wir klare teilhabe haben
müssen all das finde ich ehrlich
reichlich reichlich abwegig jetzt müssen
wir mal ein bisschen gucken dass es
nicht ein bisschen zu durcheinander geht
ich will mal weil sie von grüner
ideologie gesprochen haben ein artikel
gefunden aus einer süddeutschen zeitung
von 2011 das steht alexander dobrindt
plant den großen wurf um ein sichtbares
zeichen für die umstellung auf
erneuerbare energien zu setzen verlangte
csu-generalsekretär dass die
bundesregierung gelder umschichten die
maximale beschleunigung des energie
umbaus sei dringend notwendig da könnte
man natürlich frank da haben sie
erkenntnisse gehabt die wir heute
dringlich brauchen warum ist ihnen
derzeit nicht so viel passiert dass wir
schon auf der sicheren seite sind das
hat es ja damals richtig und heute auch
noch so richtig und genau das ist ja
auch passiert wir haben doch einen
maximalen ausbau auch gerade an
erneuerbaren energien ermöglicht bayern
ist ja vorreiter im bereich der
wasserkraft im bereich der bio immer bio
gas im bereich der geothermie so das ist
ja alles auch da und wird ja auch weiter
verstärkt von da wir bauen die offshore
windenergie mit maximaler
geschwindigkeit aus und den leitungsbau
das heißt ja erneuerbaren energien
zwingend notwendig wir können uns ja
auch mal gern darüber unterhalten warum
die planungen teilweise so schwierig
sind und wer vor ort dann oft auch genau
die gegnerschaft anführt wenn es um
junge ausbeute dobrindt wenn sich hier
behaupten wollen wir hätten den
maximalen ausbeute in den letzten jahren
gehabt das ist doch wirklich einfach
eine lüge enorme beschleunigung von mir
seine arbeit den maximalen ausbeute wie
sie es gerade gesagt uns einfach falsch
den haben wir leider nicht gehabt in
deutschland wählen wir den gehabt hätten
wäre es heute besser dann werden wir in
einer besseren situation ist wirklich
nur leider passiert ja wenn sie meine
leute erneuerbare energien gesetz nicht
entsprechend war ganz ganz am ende dann
haben sie ja lange nicht gar nicht
gelüftet sie haben bei den windkraft
angeschaut sie haben weil der windkraft
sehr gedeckelt sie machen ein paar
tricks um die leitungen blockiert die
wir dringend brauchen von nord nach süd
chemie hofft dass in bremen worden die
an meine giere ausschreibung ist
hoffentlich ermöglicht haben dass nach
baden württemberg jemand kommt und
deswegen wissen natürlich ist es war
herr dobrindt wir ändern ist ja jetzt
gerade zum glück und dann werden wir
sehen wie wir schneller vorankommen so
jetzt machen wir ganz zum schluss weil
wir eine knappe minute noch haben da hat
der russische präsident herr dobrindt
hättest du doch schon mal angesprochen
will sich sein gas jetzt in rubel
bezahlen lassen was bedeutet das für die
haltung wir beziehen auch in näherer
zukunft erstmal weiter das gas was wir
über die verträge eigentlich jetzt
bekommen sollen in den verträgen ist
klar geregelt dass in euro oder dollar
gezahlt wird deswegen wäre das auch ein
rechtsbruch russischer seite wenn sie
diesen vertrag an der stelle brechen
würden wir stimmen uns als europäer ab
weil es natürlich nicht sinn macht dass
wir jetzt national darauf reagieren
sondern im konzert der europäischen
partner das wird jetzt am gipfel auch
besprochen aber erstmal muss man wieder
klar halten hier wird ein vertrag
gebrochen wird in kürzester kürze
embargo oder nicht gegen russland das
ist relativ egal beiden vertrag bricht
oder nicht er verfolgt ein ziel und das
ziel ist natürlich die eigene währung zu
stabilisieren
das wird für uns möglicherweise
schwerste folgen haben die noch nicht
abzusehen sind wir keine rubel hat aber
mit opel bezahlen muss der muss sich
google besorgen und das total geht ist
total offen und wir wissen alles
unternehmen um diesen krieg zu beenden
und deswegen ja es wird auch immer
wieder weitere sanktionen geben aber es
geht nicht darum dass wir jetzt die
energie abschalten können sondern es
muss auch sicht eine unabhängigkeit vom
russischen gas und energie zuführen
geben das hat es ja machen auf ihren
lorbeeren vielen ein verbrannter wir
könnten noch eine viertelstunde weiter
doch ja natürlich bereiten wir werden
sehen wie es weitergeht es gibt ein
kohleausstieg haben sich ja schon ein
bisschen bewegt zumindest gehört sich
dass ein klein wenig so an was zumindest
als zumindest ist es nicht komplett
verworfen
wir müssen aufhören vielen dank für
heute morgen weil sie müssen auch ein
sie müssen auch ganz fix reingehen jetzt
danke er die oberin danke frau brandner
die bundestagspräsidentin ist wieder da
bärbel bas
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen ich wünsche ihnen einen
schönen guten morgen die sitzung ist
eröffnet
guten morgen vorab möchte ich mich
nochmal dafür bedanken für die vielen
genesungswünsche die mich erreicht haben
herzlichen dank dafür es hat gewirkt wie
sie sehen sitze heute wieder hier
vor allem möchte ich mich aber auch noch
mal bedanken aber das geht ihnen
wahrscheinlich genauso bei meinen beiden
kolleginnen petra pau und auch katrin
göring eckardt die wirklich in der
letzten sitzungswoche und auch in dieser
sitzungswoche sehr viele termine
übernommen haben und vor allen dingen
diese sitzungsleitung zum teil bis spät
in die nacht alleine gestemmt haben
herzlichen dank
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung wählen
wir noch die mitglieder der gemeinsamen
kommission von deutschen bundestag und
bundesregierung zur aufarbeitung der
verbrechen der colonia dignidad
gewählt werden sollen auf vorschlag der
spd fraktion die kollegin isabell donath
oehri und der kollege esra limbacher auf
vorschlag der fraktionen der cdu/csu die
kollegen michael brandt und dr volker
ullrich auf vorschlag der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen die kollegin
renate künast auf vorschlag der fraktion
der fdp der kollege jens beeck auf
vorschlag der fraktion der afd die
kollegin ulrike schielke zu singen und
auf vorschlag der fraktion die linke der
kollege jan korte ich gehe davon aus
dass sie dem zustimmen ich sehe keinen
widerspruch
dann ist das der fall damit sind die
genannten kolleginnen und kollegen als
mitglieder der gemeinsamen kommission
von deutschen bundestag und
bundesregierung zur aufarbeitung der
verbrechen der colonia dignidad gewählt
viel erfolg bei der arbeit
wir kommen zur tagesordnung als
zusatzpunkt 2 sollen weitere wahlen zu
gremien aufgenommen werden auch dazu
sehe ich keinen widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen und wir setzen nun die
haushaltsberatungen fort für die heutige
aussprache haben wir bereits am dienstag
eine redezeit von insgesamt neun stunden
beschlossen wir beginnen die heutigen
beratungen mit dem geschäftsbereich des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz und das wort erhält für die
bundesregierung der bundesminister dr
robert habeck
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
guten morgen
[Musik]
lieber herr merz sie haben das dann ihre
rede mit der verstellung begonnen es
wird von zeitenwende gesprochen aber man
würde sie nicht sehen ich möchte für die
bundesregierung aber auch für mein
ministerium sagen man muss blind sein
wenn man sie nicht sie
hier
wir befreien uns einer großen
geschwindigkeit von der abhängigkeit von
russischen fossilen energien nicht nur
von den fossilen energien sondern wir
kämpfen gegen eine infrastruktur die die
abhängigkeit noch vergrößert hat
gazprom besitzt den größten speicher in
deutschland der über den letzten sommer
gelehrt wurde als vorbereitung uns in
diesem winter zugänge ross neff besitzt
eine große ölraffinerie in
ostdeutschland nord stream 2 wurde
gebaut wir haben all das korrigiert oder
sind dabei es zu korrigieren wenn man
das nicht als zeitenwende als politische
sowohl in der qualität wie in der
quantität erkennt dann will man ist
nicht erkennen
[Applaus]
ja wenn man sich davon unabhängig machen
will muss man noch für alternativen
sorgen das heißt wir bauen lng terminals
und wir kaufen die rohstoffe ein die wir
brauchen um diese lng terminals zu
betreiben der qualitative unterschied
ist nicht ist nicht daher das
herkunftsland der qualitative
unterschied ist dass wir nie wieder uns
in die hand von allen lieferanten
alleine begeben wollen das was wir
machen ist die energieversorgung in
deutschland breite auf der und sicherer
aufzustellen der weg über die glasbrücke
wird immer kürzer werden je höher die
preise sind wir bauen die wasserstoff
infrastruktur auf wir sorgen dafür dass
der hochlauf von wasserstoff stattfindet
dafür bauen wir die erneuerbaren
energien nach jahren des stillstandes
mit großer dringlichkeit aus das gleiche
gilt für die netze und wir sorgen dafür
und das ich verstehe auch warum man
darüber so wenig redet denn das was man
einspart das sieht man ja nicht deswegen
wird über effizienz und einsparung zu
wenig geredet aber es macht keinen sinn
auch bei den hohen preisen dagegen an zu
subventionieren wenn wir den verbrauch
nicht reduzieren die effizienz nach
vorne zu gehen den abschied von
interessiert energie noch in den
verbrauch mit leibeskräften voran zu
bringen das ist das gebot der stunde und
wo ich rolf mützenich und britta
haßelmann sie wir hatten eine
interessante nacht die zu einem guten
ergebnis geführt hat einem guten
ergebnis geführt hat dass gerade in dem
bereich der effizienz vorzeigbare ja ich
würde sagen ausrufezeichen setzen wird
wenn daher die parteivorsitzenden das
ergebnis des koalitionsausschusses
vorstellen so geht eine zeitenwende so
wird eine zeitenwende gemacht so lösen
wir uns aus dem klammergriff der in den
letzten jahren entweder entweder durch
unwissenheit oder durch strategische
blindheit immer enger um deutschland
gezogen wurde ja wir sind noch nicht in
der lage ein sofortiges embargo auf
kohle auf öl oder auf gas aus russland
zu verhängen dass es zuzugeben und es
ist bitter genug ist zuzugeben aber dass
wir das noch nicht können heißt nicht
dass wir nichts tun schritt für schritt
sind wir jetzt schon dabei die
abhängigkeit von öl und von kohle und
von gas in der strategie zu reduzieren
die zahlen die ich am anfang des krieges
genannt habe sie stimmen jetzt schon
nicht mehr die bundesregierung und die
unternehmen und dafür bedanke ich mich
bei den unternehmen die mit ziehen sind
jetzt schon dabei ein schrittweises
embargo umzusetzen meine damen und
herren meine damen und herren natürlich
verstehe ich
verstehe ich die dringlichkeit mit der
leute sagen macht doch schneller und
vielleicht vielleicht wäre ja auch ein
embargo dass jetzt sofort auf alle drei
rohstoffe verhängt wird der game changer
und vielleicht wäre der krieg nach drei
vier tagen in der ukraine zu ende
vielleicht aber auch nicht und die
indizien wenn man sich anschaut wie die
russischen aggression in den ländern
davor sind sprechen er dagegen syrien
georgien der angriff auf die krim dieser
aktion bei dem angriff der annexion der
krim und sie alle sind jahre jahre her
teilweise
mehrere also fast ein jahrzehnt her wir
können also nicht sicher davon ausgehen
dass die maßnahmen die wir ergreifen
könnten zu einem erfreulichen ergebnis
führen deswegen ist die politik der
bundesregierung nicht unbedacht zu
handeln sondern schritt für schritt die
voraussetzungen zu schaffen dass wir
außenpolitisch und
sicherheitspolitisches freiraum
bekämpfen um dann die maßnahmen auch
durchzuhalten die wir ergreifen das ist
das gebot der stunde eine kluge
umsichtige aber energische politik
vieles von dem was wir machen
unterstützen wir mit finanziellen
aufwendungen und zwar wenn ich auf der
haushalt von meinem ministerium schaue
mit erheblichen aufwendungen aber wir
sind auch dabei eine überförderung der
vergangenheit zurück zu fahren ich habe
schon als wir über die gebäudesanierung
gestritten haben gesagt subventionen
sind die ultima ratio in einer
marktwirtschaft sie sind notwendig um
die märkte noch nicht da sind aber da wo
die märkte schon funktionieren da kann
man sie auch zurücknehmen und ich muss
feststellen dass nach 16 jahren
unionsgeführte regierung wir eine über
subventionierung in vielen bereichen
haben teilweise glaubt man wo die leute
bewegen sich in deutschland nur noch
wenn man ihnen ein klaps einen
finanziellen klaps auf den hintern gibt
komisch dass wir ihnen erklären müssen
marktwirtschaft funktioniert und darum
geht es darum geht es jetzt in dieser
situation bei woha installation und bald
schwächelnder konjunktur richtig krise
und die kräfte des marktes zu entfalten
und zwar nicht blind zu entfalten
sondern ihm eine richtung zu geben eine
richtung die rohstoffverbrauch und
klimaschutz und unabhängigkeit
kombiniert mit wachstum und wohlstand in
diesem land das tun wir mit dem großen
geldern die meinem haus zur verfügung
gestellt worden die 200 milliarden für
den klima- und transformations- vor dem
grund haushalt der ungefähr elf
milliarden beträgt wir investieren in
wasserstoff wir investieren in
innovation wir investieren in cloud
technologie wir investieren in die in
die effizienz von antrieben und von
gebäuden so schaffen wir die neuen werk
so schaffen wir innovation in
deutschland und so schaffen wir den
wettbewerb um die innovation und nicht
den wettbewerb darüber wer am längsten
im status quo für hart
meine damen und herren
heute vor einem jahr genau hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht ein
wegweisendes urteil gefällt es lässt
sich zusammenfassen mit dem satz wer das
klima schützt schützt die freiheit das
haben die richterinnen und richter
damals geurteilt und diskret ist ging
wie ein beben durch die politische
landschaft
heute ein jahr nach diesem urteil muss
man übersetzen der darum kämpft sich von
den fossilen energien frei zu machen der
kämpft für die freiheit das war sehr
geehrte damen und herren das bedeutet
zeitenwende machen wir uns frei von den
fossilen energien erst aus russland dann
insgesamt so kämpfen wir für die
freiheit so kämpfen wir für die ukraine
für die ukraine für die freiheit
dankeschön
der bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz der erste redner in der
debatte über seinen einzelplan 09 im
bundeshaushalt 20 22 die gegenrede wird
jetzt kommen von andreas jung der sich
bereiche für klimaschutz und energie in
der unionsfraktion
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen jetzt vor einer woche hat
präsident zielinski hier zugeschaltet im
bundestag gesprochen
er hat gesprochen von bomben und raketen
auf wohnungen auf krankenhäuser
auf kindergärten auf schule er hat
gesprochen von nord stream 2 hat in
diesem zusammenhang den ausdruck
gebrauchte sei zement für eine neue
mauer zwischen freiheit und unfreiheit
in
europa
er hat an unsere historische
verantwortung für die ukraine appelliert
diese worte des frei gewählten
präsidenten der ukraine überfallen von
putin mit einem schrecklichen krieg die
wiegen schwer die treffen unser herz
unser gewissen und sie dürfen nicht
folgenlos bleiben
und wir alle wir alle müssen uns
schreiben was hätten wir früher mehr tun
müssen wie müssen wir jetzt
konsequenz zeigen und was können wir
mehr tun die antworten sind nicht
einfach aber eines möchte ich sagen mit
blick auf die ankündigung putins von
gestern mit blick auf die sanktionierung
der russischen zentralbank und vor augen
das unermessliche leid der menschen in
mario tollen und in vielen anderen orten
in der ukraine wir dürfen in dieser
situation nicht hinter unserem eigenen
beschlüsse zurückgehenden unsere eigenen
sanktionen
unterland
in einer anderen konstellation aber auch
schweren lage helmut schmidt als
bundeskanzler gesagt der staat darf sich
nicht erpressen lassen und heute gilt
das frei europa darf sich nicht
erpressen lassen und deshalb herr
minister und sehr geehrte damen und
herren der bundesregierung braucht es
hier auf jetzt eine klare eine
gemeinsame europäische antwort die
erwarten wir für die beratung der
nächsten teil
und der richtige weg ist alles zu tun um
unabhängig zu werden von russischen
importen bei der energie herr minister
auf diesem weg haben sie unsere
ausdrückliche unterstützung das ist
unser weg das ist richtig dass jetzt
genauso zu tun und ja da haben wir eine
gemeinsame grundlage nämlich den
beschluss des bundestages
klimaneutralität
2045 nach der entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts von der großen
koalition beschlossen von der ampel
übernommen und jetzt geht es darum
energiesicherheit und klimaschutz
zusammen zu bringen und deshalb ist es
notwendig dem weg den wir gehen nämlich
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien da
gibt es keinen stillstand es muss
beschleunigt werden es müssen massiv
beschleunigt werden die steigerung der
energieeffizienz die fortführung der
wasserstoff strategie das ist die
eigentliche antwort das muss
beschleunigt werden in diesem sinne
unterstützen wir auch das oster und bis
sommer pakete werden ist die inhalte
genau anschauen wir werden eigene
vorschläge machen aber dieses ziel
unterstützen wir und wenn gute
vorschläge machte dann in dem sinn wie
sie es beschrieben haben wenn
zusammengebracht wird die kraft der
natur und die stärke des marktes dann
werden wir das mit überzeugung im
bundestag unterstützen
neben oster und sommer paket braucht es
jetzt aber auch ein winterpaket es
braucht ein paket zur vorsorge auf den
kommenden winter das muss kurzfristig
auf den weg gebracht werden mit unserer
kurzfristigen antwort und mit der
vorsorge wie kommen wir wie könnten wir
über den nächsten winter kommen ohne
russische importe das muss jetzt
passieren und erstens ist dazu richtig
alles zu unternehmen um zusätzliche
kapazitäten zu erschließen und bei
anderen ländern als russland einzukaufen
in europa und international
das ist der richtige weg das
unterstützen wir
zweitens ist es richtig die konsequenzen
daraus zu ziehen dass unsere gasspeicher
zu beginn dieses winters nicht gefüllt
worden sonst so guten teilen lehrern
waren der markt hat es hier eben nicht
gerichtet und das wird so lange und das
nationale gelten das wird so lange
gelten wie gazprom 20 prozent der
deutschen gasspeicher in seinem einfluss
hat und deshalb werden wir im bundestag
morgen dieses gesetz als union
unterstützen da gilt es jetzt
konsequenzen zu ziehen
herr minister habe können sie an gemahnt
es müsse auch über einsparungen
gesprochen werden und ich sage ihnen wir
sind bereit wenn sie vorschläge machen
ohne vorfestlegungen mit ihm über die
dinge zu sprechen die in dieser schweren
situation
möglich und vertretbar sind das ist auch
ein bestandteil dieses winter paket ist
ohne vorfestlegung machen sie vorschläge
dafür wir werden darüber mit ihnen
sprechen die forderung es darf keine
denkverbote geben die richtet sich nicht
nur an sie sondern die wollen wir auch
selber beherzigen aber viertens sie
richtet sich eben auch an sie und
deshalb ist unsere aufforderung dass sie
das tun was sie angekündigt haben
nämlich dass sie ergebnisoffen und ohne
vorfestlegung prüfen auf basis des
gemeinsamen bekenntnis zum
kohlekompromiss und zum ausstieg aus der
kernenergie was in dieser situation
möglich ist welche optionen es gibt bei
der modifizierung des stilllegungs vaart
bei der kohle aber auch bei einem
möglichen weiterbetrieb der letzten drei
verbliebenen kernkraftwerke über den 31
dezember hinaus ergebnisoffen und ohne
vorfestlegung wirklich ohne
vorfestlegung dass es diese erwarten und
sie haben berichtet über eine einigung
über die entlastung ist muss zur
abfederung der
gestiegenen preise mehr geben als bisher
vereinbart wurde sie haben über dinge
jetzt diskutiert wir werden die
bewährten es muss mehr gemacht werden um
die hohen belastung von bürgern und
betrieben abzufedern wenn sie gute
vorschläge machen werden wir sie
unterstützen wir haben unsere eigenen
vorschläge eingebracht die sie nicht so
bürokratisch für das was diskutiert wird
die würden sofort ein ziel genau das
wäre die basis auch hier
zusammenzukommen und letzte bemerkung
wenn sie so vorgehen dann kann gelingen
dass wir so über der sondersitzung vor
vier wochen über die grenzen von
regierung und opposition einen breiteren
konsens zusammen kommen und mein fester
eindruck ist in dieser lage in der reha
sind wird es unserem land gut tun findet
andreas jung sprecher für klimaschutz
und energie in der unionsfraktion gilt
auch als einer der profiliertesten
politiker in diesem sektor in der union
und er hat hier deutliche unterstützung
signale richtung robert habeck richtung
bundeswirtschaftsminister gesandt in
sachen ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
wasserstoff und effizienz fordert aber
auch eine ergebnisoffene prüfung der
laufzeitverlängerung für atomkraftwerke
andreas wank die junge aus der spd
putins gegen die ukraine mit all den
konsequenzen auch für uns in den zeiten
in denen wir immer noch die folgen der
korona pandemie zu bewältigen haben und
in der zeit der
generationenübergreifenden
existenziellen zukunftsaufgaben braucht
es einen staat der stabilität schafft
und handlungsfähigkeit bewahrt und der
jung genau das verkörpert unser haushalt
den wir hier in dieser woche diskutieren
und auch genau das verkörpert der
einzelplan vom bundeswirtschaftsminister
den wir hier heute diskutieren denn mit
dem stellen wir nicht nur die
notwendigen mittel bereit um die äußere
innere und auch die soziale sicherheit
für unsere bürgerinnen und bürger zu
gewährleisten
mit diesem haushalt eröffnen wir auch
ein jahrzehnt der investition in noch
nie dagewesener höhe in klimaschutz und
in die zukunftsfähigkeit unseres landes
zusammen mit den entsprechenden
bereichen aus dem energie und klimafonds
erwähnt sind es etwa elf milliarden euro
die der ansatz mit sich bringt und die
investieren wir in
transformationsprozesse der wirtschaft
und wir unterstützen damit auch das
nachhaltige wirtschaftswachstum und die
auswirkungen der korona pandemie also
auch wirklich vollständig hinter uns zu
lassen ich finde dabei überaus
erfreulich dass der einzelplan 09 die
jetzt vorliegt im vergleich zum ersten
festgestellten ansatz um 1,8 milliarden
euro angewachsen ist allein das ist für
mich ein signal wie bedeutend und
wichtig die aufgabe ist und wie ernst
die bundesregierung diese
herausforderung nimmt
wir werden
wir werden mit diesen mitteln also in
den bereichen mobilität digitalisierung
die weiterentwicklung der
wasserstoffwirtschaft investieren
genauso wie wir innovationsförderung
vornehmen werden hilfe bei
unternehmensgründungen leisten werden
die von kohle ausstieg betroffenen
regionen unterstützen werden und vor
allen dingen auch die strukturschwäche
die wir im land auch immer noch haben
bekämpfen werden außerdem sichere mir
damit es wurde erwähnt die gasversorgung
in dem wir ausländische bezugsquellen
diversifizieren und mit massiven
investitionen auch unsere wirtschaft im
land darauf vorbereiten lng terminals
und energie umzusetzen und auch zu
nutzen vor allem werden wir aber den
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
forcieren und das will ich auch noch mal
ganz klar unterstreichen denn wenn uns
das gelingt uns von fossilen
energieträger und unabhängig zu machen
entziehen wir uns auch dieser
verheerenden preissteigerungen spirale
unter der wir gegenwärtig alle leiden
und deshalb ist das eine eine aufgabe
mit existenzieller bedeutung auch für
die zukünftigen generationen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
neben diesen massiven investitionen im
wk f ich nenne hier nochmal die 1,2
milliarden euro für die industrie zur
dekarbonisierung ich nenne ich auch noch
mal die 1,4 milliarden euro für die
schaffung von lade- und elektro
infrastruktur
ich nenne ich aber auch die zehn
milliarden euro für die energetische
gebäudesanierung
richtet sich der fokus dieses haushaltes
insbesondere aber auch auf den
innovativen mittelstand den verstärken
wollen und mit dem wir durch gezielte
fördermaßnahmen mehr wachstumsimpulse
versetzen wollen um innovation und
beschäftigung zu schaffen ich will ja
exemplarisch nennen dass wir mit etwa
drei milliarden euro in forschung und
entwicklung investieren wir stellen über
eine milliarde euro für die
digitalisierung in diesem bereich zur
verfügung im übrigen ein ansatz der sich
im vergleich zum letzten verdoppelt hat
und diesen ansatz flankieren wird dann
auch noch mal mit 2,7 milliarden euro
aus dem egf ich glaube das sind gut
investierte gelder um unsere wirtschaft
auch im digitalen bereich
zukunftsfähiger zu machen und darüber
hinaus erwähne ich auch ein neues
programm in höhe von zehn millionen euro
indem wir gemeinwohlorientierte camos
unterstützen ein bereich den es so
vorher noch gar nicht gegeben hat
als netz schließlich lernen dass wir mit
blick auf die
verstetigte haushaltsplan größe der grw
eine wichtige größe haben im rahmen der
strukturschwäche anzusetzen so wie wir
das in den letzten vergangenen
jahrzehnten auch getan haben und vor dem
hintergrund leistet auch die grw hier
wieder unverzichtbare möglichkeiten für
die bekämpfung der strukturschwäche und
die angleichung der lebensverhältnisse
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und der
junge ich nehme da ihr angebot auch
gerne freuen freudvoll zur kenntnis mit
dem vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf haben
wir jetzt schon gute möglichkeiten die
weichen in richtung transformation
unserer wirtschaft und zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres landes zu stellen ich glaube
aber dass kein entwurf nicht so gut ist
dass er nicht noch verbessert werden
könnte und dem hall und dem
parlamentarischen verfahren die war
andreas mattfeldt liebe andere
haushälter wollen wir uns den prozess
gerne stellen ich bin gespannt auf
unsere zusammenarbeit und ich freue mich
da auf vielen dank
frank junge ist für die spd im
haushaltsausschuss und betreut dahin den
19.09 wirtschaft und klimaschutz und dem
sc in dieser debatte gerade geht und
falls sie ein paar mal gestolpert sind
so wie wir die abkürzung wkf ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schwer es geht
um den energie und klimafonds
das sind bekanntlich 200 milliarden euro
die bis 20 26 ausgegeben werden sollen
wolfgang wille ist der nächste redner
für die raf die fraktion auch er
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen die regierung
muss alles tun um die heutigen krisen in
schranken zu halten die auswirkungen auf
die bürger wie auch die wirtschaft zu
begrenzen das gegenteil wird jedoch
gemacht und ihr ministerium herr kollege
habeck spielt hier eine unrühmliche
rolle
die etablierte politik leidet unter
einer dramatischen selbstüberschätzung
unter einer überschätzung der
möglichkeiten die dieses land hat aber
auch in europa und die westliche welt
das gefährdet unser land unsere bürger
und unsere wirtschaft die die nicht so
viel haben spüren es zuerst und die die
weiterdenken sagen es zuerst
die harte locker und politik in der
krise hat viele existenzen zerstört und
die staatsverschuldung gewaltig
ansteigen lassen machtpolitische
übertreibungen ich werde mir den namen
söder kosten mehr als wir uns leisten
können
jetzt hat auf den angriffskrieg in der
ukraine mit hektischen sanktionen zu
reagieren die uns mehr schaden als der
russischen regierung die sich nun
stärker china und indien zuwendet auch
das zeigt eine überschätzung dessen was
unser land aushält wir erleben es jeden
tag an den zapfsäulen
es beweist selbst erzeugte not wenn und
sie herr minister habeck nach katar
pilgern um dort um gaslieferungen nach
zu suchen die dortigen regenten sind
genauso wenig lupenreine demokraten wie
herr putin
deutsche regierung verschärfen diese
krisen und sie setzen ihre ideologische
klimapolitik noch obendrauf
europa glaubt hier den oberlehrer für
die ganze welt spielen zu können während
china weiter kohlekraftwerke baut die
deutsche politik stockt wie besessen die
brüsseler vorgaben vorgaben regelmäßig
noch weiter auf
sie von der ampel aber auch ihre
schwarzen sekundanten riskieren den
industriestandort deutschland
millionen von arbeitsplätzen und den
letzten rest noch verbliebener solidität
der staatsfinanzen
es ist krasse selbstüberschätzung
wenn man auf dem weltmarkt der erste
sein will wer das epochale hochrisiko
projekt der großen transformation
durchziehen will
wachsende summen werden in wasserstoff
strategien in anderen weltregionen wie
nordafrika gesteckt die risiken für die
energieversorgung steigen dadurch weiter
solche beträge sind der haushalt an
mehreren stellen versteckt nicht zuletzt
im sogenannten energie und klimafonds
dieser etf wurde gerade durch den
zweiten nachtragshaushalt 20 21 mit 60
milliarden euro neuen schulden
aufgefüllt vergessen sie nicht auch das
geld müssen die konsumenten und
steuerzahler mühsam erarbeiten
während der transparenz ist auch bei
vielen förderprogrammen zu beklagen
beispielsweise bei zum und gr winken
geradezu das gegenteil von transparenz
beweist das ministerium bei der
förderung effizienter gebäude der
knallharte förderstopp vom 24 januar hat
bei vielen bauherren das vertrauen
zerstört
wie die bundesregierung so auf 400.000
neue wohnungen im jahr kommen will
bleibt ihr geheimnis
die fw fraktion wird immer transparenz
verlangen vor der selbstüberschätzung
der etablierten politik warnen und die
interessen der bürger im auge behalten
die keine experimente sich leisten
können und auch nicht wollen
der bundestag diskutiert über den
einzelplan 09 so heiß dass und in dem
geht es um wirtschaft und klimaschutz
zuständiger minister ist bekanntermaßen
robert habeck vom bündnis man sich gegen
grünen im moment ist hier die stunde der
haushälter also die haushaltspolitiker
mitglieder im haushaltsausschuss die
sich äußern zum die zu diesem etat die
fachpolitiker umwelt klimaschutz
politiker werden zwar andreas jung am
anfang schon gesehen die kann man bei
vor allem später in dieser debatte jetzt
karsten klein für die fdp-fraktion
auswirkungen das völkerrechtswidrigen
krieg von vladimir putin in der ukraine
und der damit einhergehenden sanktions
sie natürlich auch in deutschland zu
spüren das spiegelt auch die ifo
konjunkturprognose von gestern wieder
die stadt von einem wachstum von 3,7
prozent
nur noch mit 3,1 prozent und in haltern
die alternativszenarien auch nur noch
mit 2,2 prozent von davon ausgeht diese
wirtschaftlichen verwerfungen führen
natürlich auch zu preissteigerungen all
das belastungen die natürlich bei
unseren bürgerinnen und bürger bei
sozial schwachen bei den arbeitsplätzen
bei den unternehmen ankommen die vor
allem natürlich auch die ente
energieintensive branche treffen die
logistikbranche die achillesferse
unserer wirtschaft und deshalb liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ist es richtig
gewesen dass sich die bundesregierung
dass ich die koalitionsfraktionen von
spd grüne und fdp schon auf ein erstes
entlastungspaket vor einigen wochen
geeinigt haben den heizkostenzuschuss
denke ohne abzüge schuss den sofort
zuschlag für von armut betroffene kinder
den arbeitnehmer pauschbetrag angehoben
haben und die pendlerpauschale
das waren wichtige zeichen schon in
dieser krise dass wir handlungsfähig
sind dass wir auch schon antizipieren
was ich in den nächsten wochen
entwickeln kann und genauso richtig ist
dass liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dass
diese bundesregierung einen ergänzungs
haushalt
liegt hat einen haushalt der abbilden
soll was aufgrund der ukraine krise noch
auf uns zukommen wir was wir jetzt noch
gar nicht voll umfänglich abschätzen
können auch das zeigt handlungsfähigkeit
und transparenz
und dass wir im zuge dieses ergänzungs
haushalts natürlich auch darüber
sprechen müssen wie die bürgerinnen und
bürger die unternehmen wie gesagt die
logistikbranche die für uns so wichtig
ist aber auch die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer die jeden morgen mit ihrem
auto in die arbeitsstätte fahren und den
wohlstand erwirtschaften die
steuergelder wirtschaften die wir hier
so gern verteilt deshalb ist es wichtig
dass wir natürlich auch über deren
entlastungen jetzt in den nächsten tagen
sprechen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich finde
es ist ein kraftvolles zeichen wenn im
anbetracht der korona krise und das
ukraine kriegs diese koalition die jetzt
gerade mal 100 tage im amt ist ein
zweites entlastungspaket heute nacht
verabredet hat das in wenigen minuten
verkündet wird das zeigt wir sind
handlungsfähig in so einer extremen
krisensituation und
sage er der minister aber sie haben
natürlich auch bei diesem ergänzungs
haushalt bei auch bei den
haushaltsplanungen jetzt die
unterstützung der freien demokraten wenn
es darum geht dass wir bei der
abhängigkeit von fossilen energieträgern
weiterkommen dass wir von den fossilen
energieträgern bekommen wie wir es auch
vereinbart haben uns ist aber auch
wichtig dass wir dazu natürlich wie wir
es für andere haben marktwirtschaftliche
instrumente nutzen nicht fand ihre
aussagen zum thema subventionen ja da
wirklich sehr treffend aber dass wir
auch dafür sorgen dass die instrumente
die im einzelplan 09 im etf stehen auch
zielgerichtet und wirkungsorientierte
eingesetzt werden es geht darum wie viel
co2 einsparungen können wir dann mit
diesen mitteln auch erzielen in den
letzten legislaturperiode gab es mehrere
bundesrechnungshof berichte die
festgestellt haben dass eben diese
wirkungszusammenhänge nicht ordentlich
funktioniert haben dass das steuerungs
management nicht ordentlich funktioniert
hat und es hat wenn wir uns gemeinsam
auf den weg machen an der stelle
nachzubessern
denn wir wollen dass die steuermittel
auch zu einem wirkungsvollen ergebnis
führen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der ukraine krieg hat natürlich auch
noch zu einer ganzen reihe von anderen
aufgaben in dem einzelplan oder neuen
irgend beim aufgabenfeld des
wirtschaftsministeriums geführt ich will
drei kurz noch am ende meiner rede
ansprechen das erste ist das thema
rüstungsexport kontrolle es muss jedem
klar sein dass wir mit unserer
bundeswehr mit den verteidigen der
verteidigungsindustrie einen beitrag
leisten zum nachhaltigkeits ziel der
vereinten nationen zur sicherung von
frieden und das muss natürlich auch bei
der rüstungsexport kontrolle die jetzt
neu aufgestellt wird berücksichtigt
werden den zweiten punkt den ich
ansprechen möchte ist der freihandel
freihandel hat sich nicht überlebt ganz
im gegenteil es ist in dieser situation
umso wichtiger dass wir uns zum
freihandel mit unseren partnern die
gleiche werte vertreten vereinbaren
und der dritte punkt den ich noch kurz
an sprechen möchte ist das thema
raumfahrt ein großer haushaltskosten
herr minister in ihrem einzel planen und
da haben wir große aufgaben es war
richtig dass wir über alle
berichterstatter lieber kollege
mattfeldt hinweg uns immer zum ariane
programm zu unabhängigen zugang zum
weltall bekannt haben das war eine
richtige entscheidung die noch mal
deutlicher wird in diesen tagen deshalb
müssen wir gemeinsam dieser konferenz im
herbst auch vorbereiten hier in diesem
haus auch mitgestalten weil er geht es
wirklich um die zukunft unserer nation
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
kassen kleines für ihr stück die im
haushaltsausschuss des bundestages dass
wir so einen beitrag zur debatte über
den etat wirtschaften und klimaschutz
und er hat schon angesprochen die
zehnstündigen beratungen des
koalitionsausschusses
der es heute morgen zu ende gegangen ist
und noch eine kleine formation für sie
in gut anderthalb stunden soll es eine
pressekonferenz zu den ergebnissen geben
zentrale frage wie kommen bürgerinnen
und bürger den an das geld das ihnen der
staat zur entlastung zukommen lassen so
interessante fragen die uns da erwarten
antworten ab 11 gehen wir natürlich live
im jetzt victor perli auch er ist
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss und
mitglied der fraktion die linke nicht
und sie machen jetzt fossile energie
deals mit katar und den arabischen
emiraten der eines brot wird durch den
anderen despoten ersetzt da gibt es
nichts schönzureden
die haben sich am blutigen jemand krieg
beteiligt die missachtung elementarer
menschenrechte vor sieben monaten haben
die grünen noch gefordert die fußball wm
in katar abzusagen weil dieses land eine
zu große nähe zu den taliban haben mit
diesem land gehen sie nun herr minister
wie sie selbst sagen großartiger weise
eine langfristige partnerschaft ein
dabei müssen wir weg von solchen
partnerschaften das bedeutet jetzt noch
viele mehr zu investieren in erneuerbare
energien und die klimafreundliche
transformation der gesellschaft und der
wirtschaft aber genau das macht dieser
haushalt nicht und das findet die linke
völlig falsch
die koalition behauptet dass sie sich
auf 1 200 milliarden euro klima paket
geeinigt haben für die nächsten fünf
jahre das handelsblatt nennt das völlig
zurecht plumpes marketing und eine
luftnummer die zwei milliarden sind zum
allergrößten teil ausgaben die schon
längst schon von der alten regierung
eingeplant worden sind zudem sind sich
eines investitionen fürs klima ein
viertel entfällt auf die streichung der
eeg umlage
hier übernimmt der staat was vorher die
stromzähler bezahlt haben das ist
natürlich richtig aber es ist eben kein
neuer cent für klimaschutz
viele menschen leiden unter den
steigenden energiepreisen die regierung
muss viel massiver gegen steuern die
entlastungs paket
ist ein päckchen das bereits durch die
hohen preise und durch die steigenden
krankenkassenbeiträge dialog heute
verkündet hat aufgefressen wird es
reicht überhaupt nicht eine warme
wohnung darf kein luxusgut werden
wir müssen arbeitnehmer arme menschen
und die mittelschichten unterstützen zum
beispiel durch die senkung auf energie
zum beispiel durch ein energie geld
durch basistarife beim strom durch eine
erhöhung von hartz 4 und der
grundsicherung
in diesen wochen zogen die
energiekonzerne besonders ab sie sichern
sich extra profite die nutzen diesen
schlimmen krieg aus um besonders starke
preise zum beispiel eine spritze zu
erheben wir finden es ist sinnvoll dass
man hier in einer sondersteuer diese
extra profite abgeschöpft und es ist
spannend dass jetzt auch
nobelpreisträger joseph stiglitz genau
das vorschlägt wir sind sehr
interessiert interessiert ob sie das
aufgreifen werden es wäre sozial gerecht
meine damen und herren es
ist auch höchste zeit dass bei den
strombörsen endlich die preise begrenzt
werden meine damen und herren die
bittere wahrheit ist dass diese
bundesregierung mehr als doppelt so viel
für rüstung ausgeben möchte in den
nächsten fünf jahren wie fürs klima wir
finden das muss dringend korrigiert
werden dazu werden jetzt linke die aus
dass beratung nutzen ich freue mich auf
die beratungen vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen felix magath
frau präsidentin herr minister liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wirtschaft wirtschaft wirtschaft diese
worte haben für mich seit der letzten
woche einen anderen klang denn es waren
diese worte mit denen wohl am irrsee
lenski die gesamte deutsche politik
gewissermaßen uns alle ja so deutlich
kritisiert hat mich hat das nachdenklich
gemacht und ich finde er hat recht wir
haben uns in der vergangenheit
aus durchaus nachvollziehbaren
ökonomischen gründen und motiven
geopolitisch falsche falsch entschieden
wir wären heute souveräner in bezug auf
importstopps etwa wenn wir uns weniger
abhängig gemacht hätten von
fossilen rohstoffen aus russland bis hin
der minister angesprochen zum verkauf
von gasspeichern an gazprom
da kommen wir gleich noch zu
meine damen und herren wer diese
zusammenhänge angesprochen hat und etwa
19 2 in frage gestellt hat wurde in der
vergangenheit belächelt oder beherrscht
das wäre ja ein rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt wenn wir
also jetzt über diese zeitenwende bei
dir so viel gesprochen wird sprechen
dann darf das keine allein
verteidigungspolitische sein es muss
auch eine energiepolitische zeitenwende
sein denn
jedes windrad
jedes windrad das wir aufstellen sichert
unser klima schützt unser klima und
schützt unsere freiheit mitgeben
solarpanel dass wir montieren werden wir
unabhängiger von kohle gas und
diktatoren
meine damen und herren die
der völkerrechtswidrige angriffskrieg in
die ukraine hat auch massive
auswirkungen auf die deutsche wirtschaft
die hohen energiepreise bedrohen gerade
die energieintensive industrie
lieferketten brechen ein produktion geht
zurück die eu hat gestern einen ball für
rahmen geschlossen und in dem werden wir
jetzt in den nächsten wochen und mit dem
ergänzungs haushalt dafür sorgen die
unternehmens unterstützen sie es
brauchen aber meine damen und herren
diese ganzen effekte treffen ja nicht
alle unternehmen aber insbesondere
auch die die sich eigentlich gerade auf
dem weg in die transformation zur
klimaneutralität gemacht haben und die
jetzt mit ihren belegschaften von großen
unsicherheiten unsicherheiten ob diese
transformation noch gelähmt kann oder es
ums große bloße überleben geht und meine
damen und herren
in einer situation in der sich die
ökologischen krisen einerseits und
ökonomischen derart zuspitzen
gleichzeitig und denn der eine kluge
transformation beide krisen adressiert
muss ein bundeshaushalt antworten auf
diese unsicherheiten und herausforderung
geben und so weit das jetzt möglich ist
tut es diese haushaltsentwurf
ich will ihnen das an einem beispiel der
stellvertreter ist für viele deutlich
machen in duisburg der stadt aus der ich
komme und die ich hier vertreten darf
diese stadt ist überregional bekannt als
stadt von kohle und stahl die kohle geht
jetzt schritt für schritt und das ist
richtig aber der stahl der soll bleiben
und er soll grünen werden drei prozent
der deutschen co2 emissionen 3 prozent
entstehen allein am standort von
thyssenkrupp steel in duisburg 3 prozent
an einem standort dass das zehnfache des
gesamten innerdeutschen flugverkehr ist
gleichzeitig 17.000 arbeitsplätze gut
bezahlte arbeitsplätze auf diesem einen
standort auf einem werksgelände fünfmal
so groß wie monaco diese zahlen machen
deutlich wie groß die herausforderung
ist aber die sachen auch deutlich die
riesig der hebel ist wenn uns diese
transformation gelingt chorisch den
klimaschutz sozialen und ökonomischen
gute arbeitsplätze und deswegen geben
wir in den nächsten jahren 14 milliarden
euro für den umbau der industrie aus für
klimaschutz differenzbeträge kamen
context for difference wir fördern eine
wasserstoff-infrastruktur im
industriemaßstab
verdoppeln die ausbau kapazitäten für
elektrolyse anlagen schaffen eine
wasserstoff außenwirtschaft wie sie sie
noch nie gab all das tun wir damit die
unternehmen die jetzt diese unsicherheit
haben sicherheit für ihre investitionen
haben die jetzt anstehen und wir
und wir sorgen dafür dass die emissionen
im energiebereich im gebäudebereich
zurückgehen und gehen weg vom prinzip
der vorgänger-regierung staatlich zu
fördern was eh schon state of the art
ist hin zum prinzip maximale co2
einsparung pro euro den der staat zahlt
das ist kluge politik und wir haben noch
viel anderes vor aber die grundlage von
allem meine damen und herren ist der
massive der beschleunigte der
ambitionierte und flächendeckende ausbau
der erneuerbaren energien und herr jung
ich habe mich sehr gefreut über das was
wir gesagt haben die unterstützung
vielleicht telefonieren sie mal mit
hendrik wüst oder markus söder denn wenn
wir diesen ausbau wollen dann müssen
wünsch ausbau blockade gesetze die 1000
meter in nrw und cnh in bayern endlich
der vergangenheit an es ist doch absurd
dass die landesregierung die
cdu-geführte landesregierung nrw morgens
im letzten jahr sagt wir wollen fünf
jahre früher klimaneutralen am gleichen
nachmittag 1000 meter abstand für ihn
stehe dagegen über der wohnbebauung
beschließt das blockiert den ausbau
damit gewinnt man vielleicht waren aber
nicht die zukunft wir wollen die zukunft
gewinnen dieser haushalt ist eine gute
grundlage wir werden weiterarbeiten
vielen dank ich freue mich drauf
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
hansjörg durz
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen meine damen und herren
nichts weniger als eine zeitenwende
erleben wir seit dem 24 februar übrigens
exakt seit einem monat
nur in diesem haushaltsentwurf ist diese
zeitenwende nicht angekommen
wir sprechen ja jetzt schon von einem
ergänzungs haushalt
dieser haushaltsentwurf ist noch geprägt
von der vorgänger krise also von der
korona krise und übrigens auch von der
vorgängerregierung
die grundpfeiler dieses wirtschafts
haushaltes tragen nach wie vor die
handschrift von peter altmaier
kernelemente dieses einzel planes kann
man auch deshalb übrigens gut
unterstützen
das gilt sowohl für die deutliche
steigerung der ausgaben im bereich der
digitalen agenda wo weitgehend bisherige
projekte fortgeführt werden als auch für
die höheren ausgaben im bereich der
luft- und raumfahrt geld fließt sind
viele projekte die von der union aufs
gleis gesetzt wurden das geld für den
aufbau einer souveränen cloud-dienst
infrastruktur garics oder bei maßnahmen
zur innovationsförderung stichwort
agentur für sprung innovationen schön
dass auch ein grüner wirtschaftsminister
die prestige projekte seines schwarzen
vorgängers fort führt die ideen scheinen
offensichtlich gar nicht so ganz
schlecht gewesen zu sein
doch in den in den tiefen dieses
haushaltes finden sie natürlich auch
klassisch grüne themen diese zwei
milliarden mehr sind bereits
angesprochen worden die ausgangs kapitel
ausgaben kapitel die davon am meisten
profitieren sind die bereiche
klimaschutz energie und nachhaltigkeit
darin finden sich projekte wie die
unterstützung von real laboren oder von
klimaschutz kampagnen ich stelle mir
aber die frage wie wollen sie die ganzen
förderprojekte und sie haben vorher eine
ganze reihe von förderprojekt aufgezählt
wie wollen sie die alle administrieren
wenn sie das bundesamt für wirtschaft
und ausfuhrkontrolle nicht ausreichend
mit stellen ausstatten und ich stelle
mir zum zweiten die frage wo bleiben
denn jene die die energiewende am ende
in unserem land umsetzen wer installiert
den wärmepumpen in den häusern wer
schraubt denn die solaranlagen auf
unsere dächer herbig ist es ausgerechnet
der mittelstand der in diesem
haushaltsentwurf der große verlierer ist
im haushalts- kapitel mittelstand
kürzen sie 200 millionen euro heraus das
ist das völlig falsche signal an die
menschen und unternehmen die die
energiewende in unserem land umsetzen
doch die unternehmen wollen nicht nur
unterstützung etwa für forschung und
entwicklung sie wollen von ihrem
wirtschaftsminister vor allem hören ob
die zeitenwende die in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik angekommen ist auch
eine zeitenwende in der
wirtschaftspolitik ist davon ist in
diesem haushalt nämlich bisher nicht
viel zu sehen angenommene werte für
inflations- und wachstumszahlen sind
längst überholt es gar kein vorwurf
sondern ist schlicht fakt und in diesem
sich eintrübenden wirtschaftlichen
umfeld erwarten unternehmen zunächst
einmal eines dass sich der
wirtschaftsminister dafür einsetzt dass
sie nicht noch mit zusätzlichen
belastungen
traktiert werden ihr kollege christian
lindner forderte am dienstag hier alles
vermeiden was menschen und betriebe
weiter belasten könnte herr habeck
springen sie über ihren schatten sagen
sie ja zu einem belastungsmoratorium und
wenn sie schon nicht auf uns hören dann
doch zumindest auf ihren finanzministern
zudem hätten die unternehmen die
besonders an dem song unter dem
sanktions erschien leidend jetzt
wirklich gerne gewusst wie die von ihnen
versprochenen schutz maßnahmen aussehen
doch während die merkel-regierung es
schafft er in weniger als drei wochen
nach den corona ausbrüchen von heinsberg
erste konkrete unterstützungsmaßnahmen
vorzustellen gelingt ihnen das mit einem
kleineren hilfspaket bisher nicht wo
sind denn diese maßnahmen
in den vergangenen wochen
mussten wir alle lernen dass viele
frühere überzeugungen durch den
russischen angriffskrieg obsolet
geworden sind dazu gehört die annahme
russland mit wirtschaftlichen
abhängigkeiten einbinden zu können wir
begrüßen es deshalb dass sie sicher habe
ich derzeit redlich bemühen alternative
quellen für gas und öl in der welt auch
zu tun um die energieversorgung in
unserem land sicherzustellen
ich habe übrigens respekt davor herr
habeck denn ich bin mir sicher dass
ihnen das auch nicht leicht fällt denn
bei ihren gesprächen mit den scheichs
beugen sie sich nicht nur den realitäten
sondern mit sicherheit platzen
gleichzeitig auch grüne träume
natürlich sind
energielieferungen natürlich sind
energielieferungen aus diesen ländern
eine alternative eine energiepolitische
strategie die wir übrigens noch nicht
sehen darf aber das ist ihnen auch klar
nicht bloß vom 2 zum streichen sie muss
gerade jetzt
technologieoffen und ohne denkverbote
alle möglichkeiten übrigens auch alle
möglichkeiten in unserem land in den
blick nehmen und fehler der
vergangenheit vermeiden denn wir wollen
alle schließlich wir wollen alle
schließlich
diversifizieren also uns breiter
aufstellen und deutschland darf sich
energiepolitisch nie wieder in eine
solche abhängigkeit kriegt begeben
stattdessen bekommen wir dieser tage
deutlich vor augen geführt wie wichtig
es ist gleichgesinnte partner an der
seite zu haben und deshalb gilt es jetzt
zu ratifizieren auch dazu gibt es ein
urteil des bundesverfassungsgerichtes
habe zu einer zeitenwende in der
wirtschaftspolitik gehört auch engere
zusammenarbeit mit demokratien ebenen
sie jetzt ca der zusammenarbeit mit
kanada den weg wenn nicht mit kanada mit
wem denn dann und wenn nicht jetzt wann
dann und zwar nicht nur aus ökonomischen
gründen sondern auch als klares signal
an die autokraten dieser welt vielen
dank
mit hans jörg butt sind die
fachpolitiker ans pult zurückgekehrt in
der debatte über den einzelplan
wirtschaft und klimaschutz für den
bundeshaushalt
2022 das werden sie auch bei den
folgenden redner rennen bemerken verena
huber zum beispiel ist die nächste
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
spd-fraktion und da zuständig unter
anderem für den bereich wirtschaft
[Applaus]
präsidentin herr minister liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bleibt alles
anders und zwar anders als wir es uns
erhofft haben
anders als wir gedacht haben dass
corinna noch nicht vorbei
und schlimmer als wir befürchtet haben
herrscht ein krieg in der mitte unseres
kontinents und das ist eine katastrophe
für die menschen in der ukraine
wer aber darauf wartet dass alles wieder
so wird wie es einmal war wird
vergeblich warten müssen
wir sehen die wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen dieses kriegs höhere
energiekosten
unterbrochenen lieferketten verlust von
handelspartnern und es zeigt auch die
bestehenden schwächen unserer wirtschaft
der letzten jahrzehnte unsere starke
abhängigkeit von rohstofflieferungen aus
einzelnen ländern aber auch von fossilen
energieträgern
wird jetzt aber alles immer schlechter
und da sage ich ganz klar nein ich bin
überzeugt deutschland bleibt auch die
stärkste wirtschaft auf diesem kontinent
in europa
und wir bleiben soziale marktwirtschaft
aber wir werden sie weiter entwickeln
hin zu einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft
die auf erneuerbare energien setzt
ressourcen effizient verwendet und
nachhaltig arbeitet und dafür müssen wir
einiges ändern ja und das wollen
vielleicht manche nicht in diesem land
aber wir schonen damit die wirtschaft
stabil bleibt haben wir maßnahmen
eingeleitet um die direkten folgen die
wirtschaftlichen folgen des krieges
abzufedern wir werden nachher noch ein
entlastungspaket vorstellen aber das
wird nicht reichen
wir müssen auch an die wurzel des
problems und langfristig agieren wir
brauchen nachhaltiges wachstum das
bedeutet dass wenn ich überall geld
drauf werfen und fördern was da ist
sondern das was in der zukunft wachsen
kann und mit dem klima und
transformations- fonds machen wir das
200 milliarden sind dort drinnen und
damit werden wir ein nachhaltiges
instrument schaffen für diesen wandel
bei allem wandel 1 wollen wir bleiben
und das ist ein bruch
technologiestandort damit das so bleibt
wie es schon waren müssen wir auf
innovation setzen und dafür sind über 5
milliarden euro in diesem
wirtschaftsraum halt vorgesehen zu
zukunft gehört aber auch zu schauen wo
müssen wir dennoch gezielt rein
investieren unter anderem in unsere
mikro chip technologie und industrie und
das tun wir mit rund 2,7 milliarden geld
ist das eine wir brauchen aber auch die
leute die anpacken und umsetzen und
deswegen brauchen wir auch neuen
gründungs geist in diesem land es gibt
viele ideen die zu kleinen und großen
unternehmen führen und wir brauchen vor
allen dingen auch mehr große unternehmen
die aus innovation entstehen und hier
müssen wir die rahmenbedingungen run von
wachstumskapital bis mitarbeitenden
beteiligung ist ein stichwort genannt
und hier liegt auch der haushalt und
unser koalitionsvertrag die grundlage
wir haben viele chancen in diesem land
wir sind chancen land wir müssen die
chancen besser nutzen bei der
einwanderung zum beispiel wir haben eine
starke willkommenskultur in deutschland
aber die bürokratie die steht doch
manchmal im wege wenn es schnell gehen
muss und wir sprechen nämlich deswegen
explizit doch nicht nur von einem
fachkräftemangel sondern es ist ein
kräftemangel uns fehlen die leute
überall um auch diesen wandel
mitzugestalten und deswegen müssen wir
moderner werden wir müssen schneller
werden digitaler in unseren planungs
beschleunigungen und wir brauchen auch
insbesondere für unsere wirtschaft
weniger bürokratie und das packen wir
als starke
querschnittsaufgabe in dieser regierung
an die für fortschritt steht
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat gestern
sehr gut eines auf den punkt gebracht er
hat gesagt große krisen sind immer auch
ein anstoß für aufbruch und veränderung
in deutschland sind wir gut dinge
weiterzuentwickeln aber wir tun uns
manchmal schwer auch völlig neue wege zu
gehen ja es ist vieles nicht mehr so wie
vorher wie vor krone und vor dem
angriffskrieg eben anders in dieser
neuen zeit
jetzt habe ich in meiner rede viel über
1 gesprochen vielleicht ist dem einen
oder anderen profi tat auch bekannt es
ist nämlich eine zeile aus einem song
von herbert grönemeyer
und ich würde gerne mit einem appell
ebenfalls aus grönemeyers text enden
genug ist zu wenig gehen wir voran
verena hubert stellvertretende
vorsitzende der spd-fraktion endet mit
einem zitat von herbert grönemeyer ja
und hier geht es weiter in der debatte
und zum thema wirtschaft und klimaschutz
mit live ire colm aus der afg fraktion
da ist er stellvertretender vorsitzender
sehr geehrte bürger frau präsidentin
meine damen und herren heute morgen habe
ich den fernseher eingeschaltet um mal
zu schauen wie es dann nun wird mit den
energiepreisen es stieg kein weißer
rauch auch heute herr minister kamen
auch kein weißer rauch hier in der
debatte wir müssen also jetzt bis 11 uhr
warten dafür kam aber ein bericht aus
italien in italien liegen die
benzinpreise mittlerweile schon wieder
auf vorkriegsniveau dank einer einfachen
steuersenkung unsere bürger fahren in
belgien tanken fahren in frankreich
tanken in polen tanken weil die alle
schon was für ihre bürger und
unternehmen getan haben und sie kommen
hier nicht aus dem knick herr minister
seit wochen doktoren sie hier um gelang
es rom gezerre am tank rabatt mobilitäts
geld steuer lösungen dass es wirklich an
peinlichkeit kaum zu überbieten elf
stunden verhandlung hatte nach elf
stunden für eine ganz einfache sache
schnell und unkompliziert möglich allein
die senkung der energie steuer auf eu
minimum würde das tanken um etwa 30 cent
je liter erträglicher machen das kriegen
wir auch da bin ich mir ganz sicher ganz
schnell durch den bundestag also kommen
sie endlich in die pötte
aber vielleicht haben sie es auch gar
nicht so eilig ihn sind die hohen preise
ja sogar ganz recht es geht schließlich
um die große transformation um eine
ideologisch verbohrte energiewende die
vorne und hinten nicht funktioniert und
man sieht an ihrem haushalt dass sie
trotz der aktuellen lage weiter machen
wie bisher sie wollen die zuschüsse für
e autos noch einmal drastisch erhöhen
von 16 auf fünf milliarden euro
600 millionen wollen sie fürs klima und
biodiversität im ausland ausgeben ist
das jetzt wirklich wichtig frage ich sie
wenn sie glauben dass sich deutschland
das immer noch leisten kann dann ist die
zeitenwende von der sie herr minister
auch gesprochen haben in der regierung
offensichtlich noch nicht angekommen
für uns ist klar was zu tun ist wir
müssen schnellstmöglich runter von den
hohen energiepreisen thema inflation
ganz ganz dringend und wir müssen für
energiesicherheit sorgen und das geht
eben ganz sicher nicht mit noch mehr
erneuerbaren energien die machen uns
nämlich nicht unabhängiger sondern
zusätzlich auch noch wetter abhängig
weil jetzt ist klar wir brauchen einen
gesunden grundlastfähigen energiemix und
dazu gehört auch die kernkraft belgien
hat gerade den geplanten atomausstieg um
zehn jahre verschoben bei uns wird
behauptet das ginge nicht sagt
jedenfalls das zuständige
umweltministerium das ja eine
laufzeitverlängerung geprüft hat im
arbeitgeberverband wird schon von einer
expertin freien prüfung geht es zu recht
wörtlich heißt es in dem bericht auch
weiter der öffentlichkeit wurde
kompetenz vorgetäuscht die smb mv nicht
gibt und der eigenen ministerkollege
also sie herr arbeit wurde die portal
ist dies deswegen weil ein weiterbetrieb
von sechs kernkraftwerken die mit
abstand wirkungsvollste preisgünstigste
und am einfachsten umzusetzende maßnahme
wäre mit der die versorgungssicherheit
für strom auf umweltfreundlichem wege
maßgeblich erhöht werden könnte zitat
ende exakt das ist das was wir seit
jahren sagen für eine schnelle lösung
der energieprobleme und umweltprobleme
haben möchte dann kommt an der kernkraft
nicht vorbei und deshalb ist es zeit
herr minister dass sie dieses thema zur
chefsache machen dass sie es da hin
zurück holen wo dieses thema hingehört
ins wirtschaftsministerium
handeln sie endlich ansonsten müssen sie
sich nicht wundern dass sie vor den
scheichs weiter tief bücken müssen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp fraktion
reinhard houben und reinert oben müsste
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
wenn es auch schwer fällt
energiepolitik für anfänger wo kommt er
her im moment lieferland nummer eins
russland lieferland nummer zwei
kasachstan peter herold nehmen sie das
zur kenntnis meine damen meine
damen und herren deutschland braucht
einen innovativen wettbewerbsfähigen
mittelstand deswegen sind im
vorliegenden haushalt
innovationsförderung digitalisierung und
die förderung von gründergeist und
selbstständigkeit mit hohen posten
eingeplant ich persönlich möchte aber in
meinen drei minuten auf zwei zahlen
einlegen erste zahl lautet 2,5
milliarden euro
2,5 milliarden euro sind für den bereich
luft- und raumfahrt im haushalt
vorgesehen aber
raumfahrt ist eine entscheidende
grundlage für unser alltägliches
modernes leben maßgebliche
technologische neuerungen gerade im
bereich medizin sind auf raumfahrt
angewiesen und satelliten stellen sicher
unter anderem navigation und vernünftige
wettervorhersagen länder wie frankreich
und italien haben das erkannt sie setzen
ein zeichen und erhöhen ihre mittel
gerade in ihren nationalen programmen
dort gibt es sicherlich möglichkeiten
für die bundesregierung mehr zu
investieren gerade vor dem hintergrund
dass durch die nicht zusammenarbeit mit
russland natürlich wie auch nicht mehr
die fähigkeit haben mit entsprechenden
raketen den raumfahrt betrieb weiter
aufrecht zu halten und eine zweite zahl
sind fünf milliarden euro in unserem
haushalt
5 milliarden für den kauf von
elektroautos und ich stelle die frage
erstens geben die marktpreise nicht eine
zusätzliche
attraktivität des elektroautos her ist
es wirklich so dass wir es ist sinnvoll
die co2 reduzierung auch im verkehr zu
setzen ist es aber sinnvoll hier so viel
geld einzusetzen
denn kann die nachfrage in diesem jahr
überhaupt in der geplanten höhe
befriedigt werden und ich stelle auch in
diesem zusammenhang die frage inwieweit
plug-in-hybride wirklich die eierlegende
wollmilchsau gerade unter den
bedingungen der co2 reduzierung sieht
deswegen
deswegen meine damen und herren
rege ich an dass wir unter den ampel
partnern einmal eruieren ob wir nicht
diesen haushaltsposten
reduzieren und dafür den haushaltsposten
gerade für das nationale
weltraumprogramm erhöhen ich glaube das
ist die richtige zeit dafür es ist
technologisch nötig und wir haben in
deutschland genug know-how genug
industrie gerade auch mittelständische
industrie diese an dieser stelle
unterstützen sollten vielen dank
sagt reinhard houben und der ist
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion und wir bleiben beim sprechen
für dieses themenfeld und kommen zum
sprecher für energie und klimaschutz der
linksfraktion und das ist ralph lenkert
erwartet schon darauf dass er von
bundestagspräsident in bärbel bas
aufgerufen wird die nach einer corona
infektion jetzt wieder da ist genauso
wie bundestagsvize präsidentin einer nö
sie wird wieder tätig ihn in dieser
woche im parlament
als techniker bin ich es gewohnt im
gesamt prozessen von anfang bis ende zu
denken und das ist auch in der
wirtschaft gerade bei der energie
erforderlich leider macht dass bmw das
nicht ein beispiel durch spekulation
explodierende energiekosten die
glashersteller geraten unverschuldet in
not vielen droht die insolvenz aber ohne
glas gibt es nicht nur keine flaschen es
gibt keine fenster für die energetische
sanierung keine ampullen für medikamente
und auch keine glasfaser verschwindet
hinter
wenn die glasindustrie in
schwierigkeiten schlittert dann liegt es
auch daran dass diese koalition die
symptome bedeutet statt lösung
anzubieten sie prüfen die qualitäts
hilfen das reicht nicht
das genauso unzureichend wie die
unterstützung für menschen mit niedrigen
einkommen
gleichzeitig klettern die erlöse für ehe
und trotz corona von 41 milliarden euro
im jahr 2019 auf 77 milliarden
2021 für rwe im gleichen zeitraum von
13,6 milliarden euro auf 24,89 euro und
die profite klettern weiter
die linke fordert gegen diese
spekulation vorzugehen wir brauchen eine
preisaufsicht und eine preisfestsetzung
nach herstellkosten
diese extra profite müssen dringend
abgeschöpft werden dieses geld benötigen
wir für sozial gerechte energiekosten
für die menschen und für tragbare
energiepreise für die unternehmen auch
für die glasindustrie in thüringen und
franken
kolleginnen kollegen
nur der ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
schützt uns zukünftig vor preis
explosion bei erdgas und erdöl
jeder kubikmeter erdgas jeder liter
erdöl in deutschland nicht braucht senkt
die einnahmen von aggressiven autokraten
russland von russland bis arabien gibt
es dann weniger geld zum waffenkauf
zehn milliarden euro mehr für die
energiewende bedeutet mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit bringt mehr für den
klimaschutz und deutlich mehr für die
internationale sicherheit als 100
milliarden für die aufrüstung vielen
dank
das lenkrad war das spricht ja für
energie und klimaschutz in der
linksfraktion und nächste rednerin in
dieser ersten beratung des etats für das
ministerium wirtschaft und klimaschutz
wert lisa barth um sein für fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen und sie ist opfer
im ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kollegin kollegen ja es ist wahr robert
habeck ist grüner und er hat in katar
und auch hier offen gesagt dass
abhängigkeits energien eine schmutzige
kehrseite haben und wenn wir ehrlich
sind wussten wir dass all die jahre das
wir mit unseren geldern für kohle öl und
gas auf gewalt und unterdrückung
finanzieren und gerade weil wir diese
abhängigkeit nicht sofort beenden können
ist es so wichtig dieses dilemma diese
abhängigkeit schonungslos zu beleuchten
so lange bis wir sie endgültig beseitigt
haben einen sehr geehrten damen und
herren
[Applaus]
oder wie der spiegel schrieb die neue
deutsche ehrlichkeit das strategisches
dating sie ob ihr es ist grün
denn nur weil bei uns zur arabischen
staaten hin gewandt haben und das haben
sie hier alle offensichtlich bemerkt
heißt das doch nicht dass wir nicht mit
weiteren ländern 100 prozent erneuerbare
klima partnerschaften richtung grüner
wasserstoff richtung transformation der
wirtschaft anstreben müssen das wollen
wir und das können wir doch meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren
die zahl der verbündeten wächst auch in
europa der green deal wird aktuell in
brüssel verhandelt und das ist der
schlüssel zu unserer unabhängigkeit von
interessieren dieser schlüssel über
denen wird in brüssel gerade diskutiert
und die eu kann eine gas reduktions
strategie verabschieden effizienz und
erneuerbaren ziele anheben und ehrlich
gesagt ehemalige bremser wie polen und
an diesem zeit der zeitenwende vorne mit
dabei die fordern mehr tempo für
erneuerbare denn es ist klar solange wir
die klimakrise und kriege mit
europäischen und mit deutschen geldern
finanzieren bleiben wir unfreiheit
bleiben wir abhängig deswegen setzt
freiheit in der energiepolitik voraus
diese in der verantwortung zu ende zu
denken
in jeder einzelentscheidung hinein und
auch vor ort hinein und deswegen werde
ich nicht müde zu wiederholen die 10h
regel in bayern muss abgeschafft werden
vielen dank
lisa warum die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen mit einem appell richtung und
bayern von dort ist ja heute der appell
wiederum gekommen vom
ministerpräsidenten und csu vorsitzenden
markus söder die laufzeit der
atomkraftwerke zu verlängern sonst so
hat er getwittert drohe ein kalter
winter thomas so gibt ist der nächste
redner in dieser debatte obmann im
ausschuss für klimaschutz und energie
und frittieren dienstag zu einer sehr
geehrten damen und herren der krieg den
putin gegen die ukraine für der wert von
tag zu tag
brutaler und dieser krieg macht uns von
klarer und führt uns vor augen dass es
notwendig wird das wir notwendig im
wahrsten sinne des wortes um die not zu
binden dass wir so schnell wie möglich
unabhängig werden von diesen importen
von russischen energieträgern von öl
kohle und öl und gas meine damen und
herren wir müssen so schnell wie möglich
unabhängig werden und diese
kriegsmaschinerie nicht immer weiter zu
finanzieren sei es auch indirekt und wir
müssen unabhängig werden um sicher zu
stellen damit auch im nächsten winter
bei uns die wohnungen nicht kalt werden
und die industrieanlagen die auf gas
angewiesen sind nicht abgeschaltet
werden müssen
meine damen und herren wir
unterstützen die maßnahmen die sinnvoll
sind um diese ziele zu erreichen
es wurde angesprochen wir stimmen morgen
zum beispiel hier im deutschen bundestag
ihrem gesetz zu wonach die betreiber von
gasspeichern füllstand vorgaben
einhalten müssen und wir stimmen dem
nicht nur zu wir haben es aktiv
unterstützt wir haben auf die formale
anhörung verzichtet aus einem einzigen
grund damit dieses gesetz schnell in
kraft treten kann damit es auch bereits
in diesem frühjahr und in diesem sommer
seine wirkung entfalten kann und ich
sage ihnen wir werden weiter sinnvolle
maßnahmen an dieser stelle ausdrücklich
unterstützen
aber meine damen und herren
was wir jetzt eben brauchen und zwar
unverzüglich
und das ist ihre aufgabe
herr minister habe ich sie müssen jetzt
unverzüglich alle handlungsoptionen auf
den tisch legen alle handlungsoptionen
etwa die stromerzeugung zumindest aus
den ungehobelten gaskraftwerken
reduzieren und ersetzen die drei kohle
kernkraftwerke länger laufen lassen neue
lieferquellen für gas erschließen dass
sie nur drei optionen von einer ganzen
reihe und all diese optionen sie müssen
jetzt auf den tisch und sie müssen vor
allem sauber und ehrlich bewertet werden
das ist der entscheidende punkt was
bringen sie was kosten sie wie schnell
können sie überhaupt dazu beitragen das
problem zu lösen und was bedeuten sie
geopolitisch auch etwa für die
menschenrechte und da gehört eben auch
die frage dazu herr minister habig ist
es wirklich klug um sich aus den armen
von putin zu befreien sich in die arme
des emirs von katar zu werfen ich bin
gespannt was man ihr fünf und zehn
jahren dazu sagen wir
noch ein punkt wir reden über
kurzfristig notwendige maßnahmen es ist
ein muss
dass wir unser ziel
klimaneutral zu werden dabei immer
konsequent mitdenken und das erwarte ich
von einem guten plan dass wir die
kurzfristigen maßnahmen jetzt so angehen
dass sie unserem dass sie dem
klimaschutz nicht im wege stehen sondern
dem klimaschutz dienen erneuerbare
energien ausbauen wind und sonnenenergie
erneuerbare kraftstoffe zum beispiel aus
rest- und abfallstoffen und vieles mehr
ein letzter punkt
die steigenden energiepreise
sie werden für immer mehr menschen in
diesem land zu einem immer größer
werdenden problem übrigens auch für
viele unternehmen und
was wir brauchen ist eine effektive
entlastung wir haben dazu vorschläge
gemacht etwa die mehrwertsteuer
reduzieren die energie steuer reduzieren
das waren sind vorschläge die schnell
umzusetzen wären die unbürokratisch
werden und es ist jetzt wirklich ein
gebot der stunde und es ist allerhöchste
zeit dass die regierung so wie andere
europäische regierungen auch an dieser
stelle effektiv handelt
ja
zur wahrheit gehört
diese maßnahmen über die wir reden
kosten den staat geld
aber umso wichtiger genau aus diesem
grund umso wichtiger wäre es dass sie
gerade in einer solchen situation
prioritäten setzen worauf kommt es jetzt
wirklich an worauf kommt es jetzt
wirklich an und sich einfach nur über
beide ohren verschulden die inflation
immer weiter nach oben treiben lassen
das ist eine politik die am ende die
menschen in diesem land ärmer macht und
es macht vor allem diejenigen ärmer die
ohnehin nur wenig haben das ist nicht
der weg in deutschland gehen sollte und
deswegen fangen sie endlich an und
setzen sie prioritäten
herzlich
thomas gebert war das aus der
unionsfraktion obmann im ausschuss für
klimaschutz und energie noch eine gute
dreiviertelstunde übrigens meine damen
und herren dann gibt's pressekonferenz
der parteivorsitzenden zu dem was hier
die ganze nacht über beraten worden ist
hinsichtlich entlastungen für
bürgerinnen und bürger
das ganze wird hier direkt am
reichstagsgebäude statt finden wir
zeigen ihnen das selbstverständlich live
aber zunächst matthias müller stehen
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der spd
fraktion und
im anschuss und energiedebatte und
deswegen möchte ich im namen der ist für
die bundestagsfraktion mich bei ihnen
herr minister ausdrücklich bedanken das
was sie in den ersten 100 tagen
geleistet haben war nicht von null auf
hundert sondern es war von 0 auf 200 es
sind herausforderungen gewesen ich
glaube ich sehr so groß war und
deswegen möchte ich das ganz bewusst
auch hier meine redezeit nutzen herr
kollege perli von der linkspartei
es ist so schrecklich einfach dann zu
sagen
und jemand vorzuwerfen dann nach bad zu
reisen und herr gib hat es ist so
schrecklich einfach dann zu sagen ob das
richtig war ein
bundeswirtschaftsminister
er ist verantwortlich dafür zu sagen
wenn ich die konsequenzen dieses
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieges
ziehen will dann muss ich
versorgungssicherheit für diese
wirtschaft und für die bevölkerung in
der bundesrepublik deutschland
gewährleisten und dann ist es wohl zeit
ihr diese dinge zu kritisieren
ihnen nehme ich das sogar noch ab heute
die wunde opposition machen aber herr
kollege geht hat sie lasse ich nicht aus
der verantwortung und herr dort in dem
zusammenhang auch als roter kann ich
sagen ich versichere ihnen im namen der
spd bundestagsfraktion grüne träume
zerplatzen in diesen vier jahren mit
sicherheit nicht denn
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass gast was
die kolleginnen und kollegen mit mir mit
ihnen in der großen koalition erlebt
haben passiert uns mit fdp und grünen
nicht wir wissen
wir wissen dass es nur einen schlüssel
zur energie souveränität gibt und das
ist der maximale ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich warte darauf dass sie mit uns
vor ort kämpfen wenn sich initiativen
wiedergeben windräder bilden was
natürlich schrecklich einfach ist
erstmal gegen diese dinge zu sein nein
jetzt muss doch jedem klar sein es ist
im öffentlichen interesse dass wir mit
dem maximalen ausbau weiter kommt und
wenn sie diesen vorwurf machen und im
ried bundesländer gucken in denen sie
politische verantwortung tragen dann
sehen sie dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren alles andere als
zukunftsgerecht ist deswegen stellen sie
sich hier nicht hin und reden vom
zerplatzen grüner träume liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und was auch in diesem zusammenhang
passt erfahrungen der letzten jahre mit
ihnen ist wenn es dann darum geht wo
sind denn die alternativen ich habe
herrn merz bei der sondersitzung des
deutschen bundestages am sonntag vor
vier wochen glaube ich gesagt sie haben
keinen inneren kompass denn alleine das
was sie heute wieder geliefert haben das
thema man könnte mal über
laufzeitverlängerung nachdenken ist an
doppelzüngigkeit nicht zu überbieten
herr söder in bayern ganz groß und viel
da vorne weg als jemand der jahrelang
mit der suche eines atomaren endlagers
zu tun hat da kann ich nur sagen es ist
so widersprüchlich und so doppelt zügig
wenn ich jetzt für die
laufzeitverlängerung plädiere aber alles
in den letzten jahren dafür getan haben
dass kein atomares endlager gefunden
wird und schon gar nicht in bayern liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ich meine dass die fdk scheinlich sie in
ihren wahlkreisen sofort haben sie
bereit ist mag ja sein aber wer in
diesen zeiten
atomkraft als zukunftsfähig bezeichnet
dem kann ich nur sagen schauen sie doch
in die ukraine wo sind denn die
gefährdungspotenziale was wird denn
jetzt gerade in kriegerischen
auseinandersetzung genutzt
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
nein ich bin stolz uns
dass das was wichtig ist in der
zeitenwende
sicherheit zu geben auch für viele die
sorgen haben ob zb energie bezahlbar ist
dass diese ampel koalition auch heute
wieder zeigen wird dass wir die menschen
nicht im stich lassen dass wir
selbstverständlich auch energiekosten
als elementaren bestandteil der
daseinsvorsorge sehen und dass wir aus
jeder krise auch die chancen heraus
machen das ist unsere aufgabe und ich
bin froh dass wir um 11 uhr ein paket
präsentieren das diesen anforderungen
gerecht wird vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
matthias miersch etwas emotionaler in
dieser debatte und in seiner replik auf
den wir uns abgeordneten gepard und mit
einem verweis auf die pressekonferenz um
11 und wir können ihn jetzt sagen wer
daran teilnehmen wird nämlich die
vorsitzenden nena klingbeil und lang
also drei von fünf parteivorsitzenden
gleich um elf hier am osteingang im
reichstagsgebäude aber erstmal kasten
hülse für die afg fraktion minister
schwören ihre kraft dem wohle des
deutschen volkes widmen seinen nutzen zu
mehren und schaden von ihm zuwenden
leider widmen sich einige minister
weniger dem wohl des deutschen volkes
sondern vorrangig je nachdem welchen
ressort sie vorstehen dem wohl
verschiedener interessengruppen
finanzspekulanten pharmakonzernen
ausländischen rohstofflieferanten
rüstungsfirmen beraterfirmen die die
berater der ministerien beraten und sehr
deutlich den profiteuren der wind und
solar industrie dafür für das geld der
hart arbeitende bevölkerung
verschleudert knapp 28 milliarden euro
sind bereits aus dem energie und
klimafonds
eingepreist ein verantwortungsvoller
gehendes wirtschaftsministerium werde
kurzfristig die abhängigkeit von
stromimporten durch konsequente nutzung
der eigenen ressourcen vor allem der
braunkohle verringern und versuchen
deutschland langfristig unabhängig von
energierohstoffen porten zu machen
[Applaus]
kostengünstige sicher zur verfügung
stehende energie ist der schlüssel zu
allem zu einer funktionierenden und
erfolgreichen wirtschaft und damit zu
wohlstand für alle statt nun aber genau
darauf hin zu arbeiten gibt diese
bundesregierung zig milliarden euro für
sogenannte erneuerbare energien aus
praktisch handelt es sich um parasitäre
energien da sie niemals allein
funktionieren sondern immer
konventionelle kraftwerke benötigen die
dann einspringen wenn der wind nicht
weht und die sonne nicht scheint mit der
so genannten wasserstoff strategie
begibt sich deutschland wiederum in
abhängigkeit diesmal eben nur andere
länder da die wasserstoffproduktion in
deutschland aufgrund der exorbitanten
energiekosten vollkommen unrentabel ist
der einzige weg deutschland langfristig
weitgehend unabhängig von energie
rohstoffimporten zu machen ist die
erforschung und nutzung der kernenergie
mit sogenannten flüssig brennstoff
reaktoren diese sind da sicher sie
hinterlassen keine hoch radioaktive
reststoffe die in geologischen
zeiträumen gelagert werden müssen sie
verarbeiten die reststoffe der heutigen
kernkraftwerke allein mit den bei uns
gelagerten hoch radioaktiven reststoffen
könnten wir deutschland mehr als 100
jahre sicher mit strom und andere
energie versorgen und die ausbeute der
energie im verhältnis zur aufgewendeten
energie liegt bei diesen reaktoren
mehrere hundert mal höher als bei den
parasitären energien mit der hohen
prozesswärme können synthetische
kraftstoffe hergestellt werden jedweder
art die kosten für den endverbraucher
liegen weit weit unter denen diese heute
bezahlen müssen ja es wurde zeit in
anspruch nehmen aber nur ein bruchteil
der parasitären energien kosten wir
könnten uns dann auch die knapp 24
milliarden euro für die endlagersuche
sparen am ende dieses weges wäre
deutschland weitgehend unabhängig von
jeglichen energie rohstoffimporten und
hätte preiswert der energie im überfluss
allen hier ohne ideologische
scheuklappen die pragmatisch und vor
allem langfristig deutschlands
energieprobleme lösen wollen empfehle
ich unsere broschüre weiter horizont
denken wir nicht denken wir nicht in
legislaturperioden
handeln wir weitsichtig die grüne
energiewende ist gescheitert starten wir
die blaue energiewende entsprechende
haushaltsanträge werden wir
selbstverständlich einreichen vielen
dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die übung das fiel
sogar das und hier geht es weiter mit
olaf in der beek klimapolitischer
sprecher der fdp fraktion
das erklärte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
aus frauen sind doch immer
grundsatzfragen wir reden also dieser
woche nicht nur über die verteilung von
finanziellen mitteln sondern auch über
die politische schwerpunktsetzung für
die nächsten jahre in der ampelkoalition
wird der klimaschutz einen prominenten
teil in der finanzplanung und damit auch
in unserer politik einnehmen wie von
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
angekündigt werden wir bis 20 26 allein
200 milliarden euro für klimaschutz und
transformationen bereitstellen
unser anspruch unser anspruch ist es nun
jeden euro so effizient und so effektiv
wie möglich einzuplanen mit der
gießkanne überall geld zu verteilen ist
weder ökologisch noch ökonomisch
sinnvoll dabei haben wir einiges zu tun
unsere klimapolitik muss vor allem
international verankert werden ein
wichtiger baustein ist dabei der klima
club den wir im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart je mehr partner wir auf der
globalen ebene dazu gewinnen können
desto mehr werden wir auch von unseren
investitionen profitieren können
es ist das ist unser anspruch im
globalen vergleich voranzugehen neben
investitionen im internationalen bereich
müssen wir uns natürlich auch national
der gesamtgesellschaftlichen aufgabe
stellen dabei spielen instrumente wie
das klima geld eine entscheidende rolle
hier arbeitet die ampelkoalition mit
hochdruck an der konkreten ausgestaltung
auch die potenziale die sich für unsere
wirtschaft und dabei insbesondere für
industrie und mittelstand bieten müssen
wir nutzen und als staat die
bestmöglichen rahmenbedingungen dafür
schaffen
technologieoffenheit mut zu innovation
und die bereitschaft zur transformation
die ampelkoalition liefert
gut
wenn wir
wenn wir zielgenau und nachhaltig
investieren werden wir nicht nur als
volkswirtschaft profitieren sondern
gehen entscheidende schritte in die
nächst auch für die nächsten
generationen auch der herr kollegin
zudem laufe eine zwischenfrage nein auch
in der energiepolitik stehen wichtige
zukunftsinvestitionen an wir haben noch
nie so intensiv wie jetzt über die
energieversorgung in deutschland
diskutiert abhängigkeiten beenden die
diversifizierung unserer
energieversorgung vorantreiben das sind
die drängenden aufgaben der ampel dabei
müssen wir
dabei müssen wir unter anderem
schnellstmöglich entschied terminals
bauen langfristig werden wir dafür
sorgen deutschland zu energie autark wie
möglich zu machen hier geht es neben dem
massiven ausbau erneuerbarer energien
auch um gezielte
investitionen in die forschung und
entwicklung neuer technologien liebe
kolleginnen kollegen neben allen
schwierigkeiten die uns derzeit
beschäftigen müssen wir im hinblick auf
die klima und energiepolitik aber auch
über chancen reden chancen für unsere
wirtschaft chancen für unsere
gesellschaft und auch chancen für die
staatengemeinschaft
klimaschutz kann nur gemeinsam
erfolgreich sein gehen wir mit diesem
haushalt den ersten konsequenten schritt
in die richtige richtung vielen dank
olaf in der billig und wir sind schon
angekommen beim drittletzten redner in
dieser debatte nämlich bei bernd
westphal aus der spd-fraktion
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher und ich
sage es gerne noch mal dann dauert es
nicht mehr lange bis hier der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt verhandelt wird
nämlich der etat des
gesundheitsministeriums das mit dem mit
karl lauterbach und wie es aussieht
werden wir das völlig stressfrei
hinkriegen um anschließend rechtzeitig
zu schauen auf die pressekonferenz ist
der drei koalitionäre zu
entlastungspaket aber jetzt erstmal
bernd lässt landet bei dem
bundeshaushalt ist immer auch die stunde
des parlaments hier werden politische
ziele und die maßnahmen mit geld
hinterlegt und wir dürfen eins dabei
nicht vergessen wir haben das den
fleißigen arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern den innovativen und
mutigen unternehmer aber auch vor allen
dingen den innovativen start-ups der
industrie und im mittelstand verdanken
die schaffen erst die voraussetzungen
und unseren politischen spielraum den
wir hier haben finanziell was zu
verteilen
alle wissen dass
der haushalt 2022 oder ganz anderen
wirtschaftlichen rahmenbedingungen
eingebracht wird die ampelkoalition ist
in den ersten 100 tagen enorm gefordert
es sind große themen die wir
gegenüberstehen die wir bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen natürlich nicht
auf dem zettel hatten und die
regierungen der leitung von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz leistet eine
hervorragende arbeit das zeigt sich auch
durch die breite zustimmung in der
bevölkerung
mit einem diner anspruchsvollen politik
auf internationaler ebene mit einer
geschlossenheit und besonnen politik
geben wir orientierung halt und
sicherheit und jetzt kommt es genau
darauf an diesen zusammenhalt zu
organisieren in diesen schwierigen
zeiten in diesen großen
herausforderungen und dann darf man sich
nicht im klein-klein patienten und
deshalb sage ich ganz deutlich
die rede von friedrich merz gestern
morgen wird dieser verantwortungsvollen
politik nicht gerecht
aus der wirtschaft den unternehmen
erfahren wir hohe zustimmung für die
politik der bundesregierung jetzt geht
es um die schaffung sicherer
verlässlicher rahmenbedingungen für
investitionen
dadurch sichern wir das
wirtschaftswachstum der zukunft und das
heißt nicht unbedingt mehr von dem was
wir jetzt haben sondern wir müssen
besser werden nicht mehr sondern besser
werden bessere autos mit besseren
antrieben bessere energiesysteme bessere
maschinenbau mehr gut höhere effizienz
und mehr digitalisierung
und klimaschutz
und den klimaschutz werden wir dabei
nicht aus den augen verlieren nur durch
klimaneutrales wirtschaften wird es
gelingen moderne produkte neue
marktperspektiven und vor allen dingen
arbeits und ausbildungsplätze eine
sichere zukunftsperspektive zu geben die
anstrengungen zum erreichen von
klimaneutralität wird die dynamik
zulegen müssen das sichert der haushalt
in der jetzigen form ab und jeder euro
den wir investieren in erneuerbare
energien in den hochlauf der
wasserstoffwirtschaft in eine moderne
infrastruktur wird putin das
kriegshandwerk aus dem hand nehmen das
ist unser ziel mit diesen investitionen
den wir machen
dass deutschland attraktiv ist für
investitionen
das zeigen die entscheidungen in den
unternehmen in deutschland
so machen sich die stahlindustrie die
chemie die automobilindustrie und andere
auf den weg ihre produktion klimaneutral
zu organisieren und diese transformation
dürfen wir jetzt nicht gefährden aber
auch ausländische investoren wie tesla
north gold oder auch intel zeigen dass
die standortbedingungen in deutschland
optimal sind dass wir mit dieser politik
der bundesregierung einladen sind für
investoren in der welt hier in
deutschland zu investieren und das ist
ein positives und gutes zeichen
meine damen und herren
der angriffskrieg von russland in die
ukraine erfordert natürlich auch
veränderungen der wirtschaftspolitik
unsere maßnahmen die sanktionen zeigen
massiv wirkung in russland das ist die
absicht die treffen gezielt aber haben
natürlich auch auswirkungen auf unsere
unternehmen deshalb sind entlastungen
unterstützung jetzt nicht nur
berechtigterweise für private haushalte
sondern auch für unternehmen
notwendig wichtig und richtig und die
unternehmen brauchen eine stabile brücke
aus diesen krisen modus heraus zu kommen
und wieder fuß fassen zu können der
haushalt enthält hierfür die richtigen
signale und ich bin davon überzeugt dass
mit einem instrument aus dem ergänzungs
haushalt auch die stabilität und
absicherung erfolgt die europäische
kommission hat hierfür den ball für
rechtlichen rahmen geschaffen den wir
jetzt auch ausnutzen müssen wir haben
die belastungen durch corona noch nicht
hinter uns gelassen wir waren auf einem
guten weg raus in der aus der pandemie
und waren auch auf wachstumskurs und ich
will an dieser stelle noch einmal sagen
wir hätten schon viel weiter sein können
wenn wir endlich eine höhere impfquote
hätten deshalb stimmen sie dem gesetz
zur impfung eine allgemeine impfpflicht
zu wir brauchen genau diese
rahmenbedingungen liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
die lage ist zu ernst für
parteipolitische spielchen wir dürfen
jetzt die risiken aus inflation aus
geringem wachstum rückgang der kaufkraft
und lieferengpässen auf keinen fall
unterschätzen niemand möchte eine
weitere eskalation des krieges an dieser
stelle danke ich besonders dem
engagement unseres
bundeswirtschaftsministers der wirklich
mit einer sehr anspruchsvollen politik
dafür sorgt unseren wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland zu stabilisieren und auch
für die energieversorgungssicherheit zur
sorge wir in der ampel koalition
organisieren sicherheit im und durch
wandel darauf können sie sich verlassen
der haushaltsentwurf der eingebracht
wurde ist gut wir werden in der
parlamentarischen beratungen der ein
oder anderen stelle ihnen noch besser
machen herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und
das war bernd westphal der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion
drittletzter redner habe ich gesagt
jetzt andreas mattfeldt unionsfraktion
er ist mitglied im haushaltsausschuss es
könnte also noch ein bisschen konkreten
raums geld geben
herr wirtschaftsminister habe
sie sehen mich irritiert
irritiert deshalb weil sie ankündigungen
das gestern nacht wichtige
entscheidungen getroffen worden sind und
sie sagen hier im parlament schaut euch
um 11 doch die pressekonferenz ab herr
habeck das geht nicht wenn sie solche
entscheidungen treffen dann müssen sie
wenn sie wir sprechen hier im haus im
parlament anspricht
das ist eine missachtung des parlamentes
das funktioniert für mich und das gehört
sich nicht und
ich darf das auch sagen dass selten nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg
die verantwortung für ein wirtschafts
haushalte groß war wie in diesem jahr
auf eine sinnvolle
abgewogener ausgabenpolitik kommt es in
diesem jahr mehr an als denn je
wir wollen mit dieser ausgabenpolitik
und wieder in eine lage versetzen dass
wir den derzeitigen herausforderungen
die durch putins grausamsten
angriffskrieg aufgebrochen sind dass wir
diese bewältigen und das verlangt uns
weiß gott ihnen auch alles ab und sie
herr minister sie möchten zur
bewältigung dieser schwierigen
rahmenbedingungen die wirtschaft mit
ungefähr elf milliarden euro
stabilisieren das hört sich zunächst
einmal ganz viel an aber in wahrheit
sind das lediglich 700 millionen euro
mehr als noch 20 21 und ich bin sehr
skeptisch ob dieses bei den derzeitigen
vor uns liegenden problemen wirklich
ausreichend ist ich hab mal gelernt in
einer krise da muss man eher klotzen als
den kleckern vor allen dingen aber herr
minister habe ich muss man sinnvoll
investieren in bereiche die eben das
rückgrat unserer wirtschaft darstellen
investiere wirtschaftsbereiche wie heute
dazu beitragen dass mit erheblichen
steuereinnahmen auch uns in der union
notwendige klimaschutzprojekte zukünftig
und dauerhaft finanzierbar sind das sind
investitionen
in innovation in forschung weil hier
eben ganz besonders auch im mittelstand
davon profitiert werden und wenn ich das
sagen darf der mittelstand herbeck der
entwickelt hier nicht für die schublade
der mittelstand entwickelt hierfür die
marktreife weiß auch zwingend
erforderlich ist und ich hatte den
eindruck dass ihnen diese
wirtschaftszweige von industrie von
handel von handwerk irgendwie so ein
bisschen
fremd sind ich habe den eindruck sie
müssen sich da erst ein stück weit
nähern glauben sie mir wir wollen gerne
helfen dass das gelingt denn sonst ist
es glaube ich nicht zu erklären dass sie
hier massiv die mittel streichen so muss
das zentrale innovationsprogramm
mittelstand dass die mittelstand bei
innovationen unterstützt mit 35
millionen euro weniger auskommen als
noch 20 21 beim innovationsprogramm gp
haben sie sogar 49 millionen euro
gestrichen gleiches gilt für die
industrielle gemeinschaftsforschung
was aber an ihrem entwurf am
dramatischsten ist dass sie jetzt wonach
der korona krise ausländische touristen
wieder zu uns kommen können dass sie die
deutsche zentrale für tourismus die im
ausland für urlaub in deutschland wird
das in dieser organisation zehn
millionen euro ihres ohnehin schon
knappen tag um fast ein viertel kürzen
ich finde das ist schlichtweg die härte
und herr minister das ist auch immer
fällt entschuldigung erlauben sie alle
zwischen frage von herrn banaszak auch
die in frage der zeit ist immer zu knapp
vielen dank herr kollege mattfeldt für
die möglichkeit wir haben gerade gesagt
der minister hätte mit solchen dingen
wie industrie eigentlich nichts am hut
haben sie zur kenntnis genommen dass
gegenüber dem regierungsentwurf ihrer
der unionsgeführten regierung zehn
milliarden euro mehr zehn milliarden
euro mehr für die dekarbonisierung der
industrie in den nächsten jahren
vorgesehen ist damit dass alles klappen
kann und nehmen sie in dem zusammenhang
auch zur kenntnis dass es daran auch
hängt das der energie und klima vorm
wald klima und transformations- fonds
ausreichend ausgestattet ist und kann
ich ihre ankündigung dass jetzt
gekleckert und nicht das jetzt um
kleckern und nicht um klopfen oder
andersrum geht so verstehen dass sie die
angekündigte klage gegen den
nachtragshaushalt
2021 der die finanziellen möglichkeiten
überhaupt erst schafft diese
investitionen auf den weg zu bringen
zurücknehmen werden
geschätzter junger kollege banaszak wir
beide mögen uns ja sehr
aber es ist
es ist so dass wir jetzt hier über den
einzelplan 09 uns unterhalten und wenn
sie den energie und klimafonds
ansprechen freue ich mich denn da habe
ich dann gleich noch ein bisschen
munition mehr weil ich da gar nicht mehr
die zeit für die rede hatte das ist der
energie- und klimafonds der demnächst
200 milliarden euro zur verfügung steht
für bereiche die eben unter corona nicht
leiden bereiche die sowieso schon fast
extrem gut ausgestattet sind und wenn
wir dort vernünftig investieren im
energie und klimafonds sind wir ja bei
ihnen an ihrer seite wenn sie aber in
diesen haushalt hineinschauen dann sehen
sie dass eben wir nicht nur eine
klimaschutzminister haben sondern
keramik ist wirtschaftsminister einer
der größten volkswirtschaften der welt
und er ist nicht nur klimaschutz
mindeste und er kürzt hier mitte für den
für den mittelstand für die industrie
für dem handwerk und für den handel und
das findet sich hier wieder das sind
bereiche das sind bereiche die das
rückgrat unserer wirtschaft darstellen
die sie nicht kaputt machen können und
das sehen wir hier eben in diesem
haushalt und deshalb ganz deutlich wir
gretchen daran wo es erforderlich ist
und hier ist es erforderlich man kann
nicht diese industriezweige kaputt
sparen das geht einfach nicht
deshalb darf ich sagen das ist ein
schlag ins gesicht die kürzung bei der
dzt für die mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter
dort die unter der korona krise mehr als
manch andere gelitten hat es hätte sich
gehört der minister habe hier diesen
etat richtig aufwachsen zu lassen als
denn hier zu kürzen ich finde das ist
beschämend und ich darf sagen und jetzt
schon ankündigen sie werden von uns
einen sehr klugen antrag dieser richtung
kriegen und ich kenne sie ja auch sie
werden sich das zur gemüte führen und
wir beide werden darüber sprechen und
ich glaube dann kommen wir auch
vielleicht zu einer vernünftigen lösung
denn sie werden es doch den mitarbeitern
dort nicht erklären können warum sie
diese branche mit über 2 millionen
mitarbeitern keinen zusätzlichen cent
übrig haben aber gleichzeitig klima
investitionen in
biodiversität und den klimaschutz
übrigens ausschließlich im ausland
unterstützen wollen das werden die
menschen eben nicht verstehen und
gewundert das darf ich noch sagen er
habe habe ich mich auch über den fast
halbierten ansatz bei den energy bunker
schiffen jahr die verringerung hier die
ist planmäßig ja es handelt sich hier um
die ausfinanzierung eines projektes aber
sie haben es ja selber angekündigt lg
ist die herausforderung und hier jetzt
kein anschlussprojekt anzudocken das ist
fast schon fahrlässig ich glaube ich
darf das auch sagen auch bei
energiespeichern hätte ich mir hier
etwas gewünscht wir müssen doch jetzt
haushaltsansätze her hier fehlen die
ansetzung und im norddeutschen bereich
16 wir haben hier noch deutlich luft
nach oben ich glaube hier sollten wir
noch nacharbeiten aber herr minister
will auch nicht nur meckern ich möchte
auch loben ich glaube es ist vernünftig
was sie im bereich der luft- und
raumfahrt hier gemacht haben das haben
wir auch in der letzten
legislaturperiode schon gemacht dass
führen sie fort dass es klug ich habe
mich auch gefreut dass sie bei der
erschließung von auslandsmärkten die
mittel um 145 millionen euro angehoben
haben ähnliches gilt auch für den
wasserstoff auch hier haben sie die
schon von der alten regierung
eingebrachten mittel noch einmal einem
aufwuchs zuteil werden lassen dass es
auch eine kluge sache ja herr minister
habe sie haben jetzt in den beratungen
zeit gemeinsam mit uns parlamentariern
aus diesem entwurf etwas vernünftiges zu
machen sie wissen dass sie mich als
ihrem hauptberichterstatter an ihrer
seite finden bei guten ideen übrigens
alle wird berichterstatter für ihren
haushaltsentwurf vielleicht eine sache
zum abschluss her habe läuft die
wirtschaft dann läuft es auch mit dem
klimaschutz in diesem sinne freue ich
mich auf tolle beratungen in den
kommenden wochen ich bin gespannt was
dann rauskommt herzlichen dank
andreas mattfeldt short freudig in die
nächsten wochen in der april wird dann
zweite dritte lesung sein des
bundeshaushalts
2022 da wird es noch allerlei
verschiebungen geben vielleicht wird
sogar der ergänzungs haushalt
eingebracht eine abkürzung wollte ich
ihnen noch für alle felder nachliefern
die meisten von ihnen wissen lng
liquefied natural gas also verflüssigtes
erdgas nur 1 600 volumens und dadurch
leichter zu transportieren nina scheer
ist die letzte rednerin in dieser gehört
dass wir den haushalt noch verbessern
könnten aber ich muss sie doch noch
immer daran erinnern etwa die nationale
wasserstoff strategie von ihrem immer
den von unserem ehemaligen
wirtschaftsminister herr peter altmaier
vorgelegt hat gerade mal 13 prozent
erneuerbare energien für wasserstoff im
jahr 20 30 vorgesehen 13 das war die
handschrift mit der wir zu tun haben
unter ihrer wirtschaftsführung in der
koalition das war einfach nicht in
ordnung
bin ich auch froh dass dieses kapitel
abgeschlossen ist und wir brauchen uns
wirklich keine belehrungen von ihnen
geben zu lassen wie nun dieser haushalt
auf den weg zu bringen und wie die
energiewende zuständen ist und ich
möchte auch aufs schärfste zurückweisen
dass hier der eindruck erweckt wird wenn
jetzt mit mühe und not aufgrund der
aktuellen situation allen bekannten
krisen es nur notwendig geworden ist ein
zweites entlastungs paket zu schnüren
und hierbei auch nachtzeiten wieder in
anspruch genommen werden mussten alle
sich hingesetzt haben alles daran zu
setzen dass das ermöglicht wird da fällt
ihnen nichts anderes ein als hier zu
suggerieren der öffentlichkeit zu
suggerieren dass die minister nicht in
der lage sein das dem parlament zunächst
zu präsentieren das ist einfach billig
steigende energiepreise zeigen wie
schnell aus abhängigkeit von fossilen
energien handlungsstränge werden können
und insofern ist auch die energiepreise
krise die eine fossile energie
preiskrise ist
ist ein barometer sie ist ein barometer
für die verwundbarkeit von
volkswirtschaften und diese vor
bestehende abhängigkeit von fossilen
ressourcen muss eben insofern auch vor
dem hintergrund dass russland ukraine
konflikt bzw des angriffskrieges von
russland als zeitraffer betrachtet
werden wir haben ein zeitraffer der uns
schaltstellen eröffnet um jetzt akut und
drastisch zu handeln und eben auch mit
dem zweiten entlastungspaket aber auch
weitergehende maßnahmen zu handeln wir
haben morgen das gas speicher gesetz im
bundestag auch das ist eine reaktion auf
grund der aktuellen situation und es ist
auch natürlich aufs schärfste
zurückzuweisen
dass russland jetzt auch vertragswidrige
weise in rubel die energieimporte
beglichen haben möchte dass es
vertragswidrig das ist keine frage der
antwort
energiesicherheit ist zum einen eine
frage der entlastung ich es angesprochen
ich muss auch noch mal kurz betonen 15
milliarden euro wurden bereits
vereinbart das muss doch mal
festgehalten
mit stehen heute beschlossenen folge zu
stellenden maßnahmen werden des weiteren
möglichkeiten seien es sind einmalige
heizkostenzuschüsse auf den letzten
metern noch mal verdoppelt worden 710000
menschen profitieren davon und auch die
eeg-umlage die jetzt zur mitte des
jahres vorzeitig abgesenkt wird auch
diese ist natürlich eine enorme
entlastung und natürlich muss nochmals
korrigieren das ist jetzt nicht was
irgendwo jenseits der energiewende sein
nein durch die absenkung von strompreis
begünstigen wir auch wärmepumpen und
natürlich ist das ein bestandteil der
energiewende dass gar nichts passiert
energiesicherheit heißt aber natürlich
zum einen wird politisch schnell weiter
voran zu kommen deswegen sieht auch der
in der ginsheimer schutz vorm
transformations- fonds mit der neuen
bezeichnung weitere auf hitze vor das
ist ganz klar aber auch regulativ müssen
wir natürlich vorankommen und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass jetzt schnell ein
großes paket mit dem oster paket kommt
und auch weitergehende maßnahmen dass
wir die hemmnisse beseitigen das
planungssicherheit geschaffen wird dass
die aufbauten erneuerbaren energien so
schnell vorangehen die erneuerbaren
energien sie schicken uns keine rechnung
das sind frei nach franz alt dass sich
die bezahlbare energie
importabhängigkeit dringen hingegen in
geiselhaft und darauf müssen wir uns
befreien vielen dank für
nina scheer war das sprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie letzte rednerin
in der debatte der ersten beratung des
etats für das ministerium
von robert habeck also wirtschaft und
klimaschutzes wird weitere beratungen in
den ausschüssen geben unter anderem im
haushaltsausschuss und das gilt auch für
den kombi meter da geht es um den etat
des
bundesgesundheitsministers der natürlich
deutlich größer ist als der des
wirtschaftsministers und er wird auch
besondere aufgaben zu erledigen haben
ihnen kommenden jahr den sonderzahlungen
werden fällig an die gesetzlichen
krankenkassen von mindestens 14
milliarden euro allein in diesem jahr
neben dem bereits feststehenden zuschuss
von 14,5 milliarden also da wird einiges
liegt einiges im argen im moment eben
gesundheitswesen kein wunder in teil
natürlich auch der pandemie und den
corona maßnahmen geschuldet aber nicht
allein da laut aber sehen sie das schon
und wir denken dass wir ihn komplette
senden können denn sie wissen meine
damen und herren um 11 uhr soll es geben
die pressekonferenz der
parteivorsitzenden ricarda lang lars
klingbeil und christian lindner zu den
beratungen die die ganze nacht über
stattgefunden haben es heute morgen um 8
angefangen gestern um 9 aber zunächst
haben wir mal die vorstellung von
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach zu
sein
frau präsidentin nur eine sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
die panne ist leider nicht vorbei
das zeigt auch ein blick in diesem
haushaltsentwurf wer noch immer geglaubt
hat die panini würde jetzt schnell
ändern der sieht es ist leider nicht so
weit und wir haben das auch im
einzelplan 15 berücksichtigen müssen da
es zu platz 15 war ursprünglich fast nur
halb so groß wie er jetzt ist und wir
über schalten für das jetzt laufende
jahr überschreiten wir sogar den
einzelplan des letzten jahres das heißt
die kosten sind deutlich gestiegen wir
geben deutlich mehr geld aus und die
frage ist lohnt sich das wofür wird das
geld ausgegeben diese frage muss
beantwortet wird und sie kann
beantwortet werden wenn wir darauf
zurückblicken last deutschland bisher
geleistet hat wie viel wir ausgegeben
haben dann steht auf der haben-seite
dass wir im vergleich zu anderen ländern
die eine ähnliche altersstruktur haben
die deutschland die aber zum teil
weniger ältere ungeimpfte haben dass wir
trotzdem eine besonders niedrige oder
verhältnismäßig niedrige sterblichkeit
haben deutschland ist es also gelungen
bei der sterblichkeit einen erfolg zu
zeigen auf denen wir auch stolz sein
können und das muss im rahmen einer
solchen debatte auch gesagt wenn du
musst gefragt wofür machen die das ganze
wir haben das gemeinsam geschafft und es
sind nicht nur die ausgaben gewesen es
sind auch die vielen menschen gewesen
die sich an die regeln gehalten haben
die kinder die sich die masken angezogen
haben die erwachsenen die nicht die
restaurants die clubs besucht haben
diejenigen die sich an die regeln
gehalten haben sie haben den
allerhöchsten teil der kosten getragen
das sind die immateriellen kosten und
ihnen möchte ich zu beginn dieser rede
meinen ausdrücklichen dank aussprechen
auf der anderen seite sind wir auch an
einen punkt wo wir weitermachen müssen
wir müssen wir müssen uns da wir müssen
uns wir müssen uns darauf konzentrieren
200 bis 300 tote pro tag
300.000 neue fälle das ist keine
situation die wir akzeptieren können das
ist an der lage die nicht bleiben kann
wir müssen im kampf gegen brunner
weitermachen es gibt einen freundlich es
gibt keinen grund hier nachzulassen wir
müssen zusammenstehen müssen durch diese
schwere wäre der bande wir noch
durchkommen daher appelliere ich
übrigens auch an dieser stelle an die
länder wir haben hier ein gesetz gemacht
das infektionsschutzgesetz da hätte sich
der ein oder andere ein gesetz gewünscht
wo der bund regeln macht für ganz
deutschland
das ging aber nicht weil wir nicht in
ganz deutschland eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems haben das wäre dafür
die voraussetzung gewesen aber es gibt
in velen sind sie doch einfach still ich
glaube das was sie hier vorzutragen
interessiert browser ihre eigenen reihen
niemand nehmen das höre und spreche für
das gesamt aus niemand will das doch
hört das ist doch keine kunst druck denn
es ist noch was ich jetzt von der
rechten seite was ich hier höre das ist
doch nur störender lärm und so geht es
allen kollegen von mir es ist beschämend
dass man sich das anhören muss
beschämend
nein das ist nicht das parlament ist das
im parlament geht es um die sachliche
auseinandersetzung aber nicht umhin aber
nicht um hämische bemerkungen im
angesicht von 300 toten pro tag
ich appelliere an die länder ich
appelliere an die länder das
infektionsschutzgesetz was wir jetzt
gemacht haben bitte nutzen sie es nutzen
sie dieses 16 es ist richtig wir haben
nicht deutschlandweit eine überlastung
des gesundheitssystems teil waren
flächendeckende regeln waren nicht mehr
möglich aber es gibt zahlreiche regionen
wo die krankenhaus so zum beispiel
überlastet sind wo die pflege
untergrenzen unterschritten sind wo wir
die notfallversorgung abgemeldet werden
muss und verlegt werden muss wo verlegt
werden muss war nicht genug betten da
sind wo wir planbare eingriffe absagen
müssen all diese gegenden sind
überlastet und dort kann und so das
infektionsschutzgesetz ein gesetz
eingesetzt wird ich bedanke mich
ausdrücklich dafür dass das in
mecklenburg vorpommern aber nicht nur
dort untersucht jetzt versucht wird denn
wir müssen jetzt zusammenhalten wir
dürfen nicht betonen dass wir die regeln
die wir gerne hätten die aber rechtlich
nicht gehen nicht da sind sondern wir
müssen die regeln die wir gemeinsam
gemacht habe die müssen wir einsetzen
zum schutz all derer die es brauchen die
auf uns angewiesen sind
die kosten die wir derzeit tragen das
sind kosten da geht es zum beispiel um
impfstoffe die wir besorgen die
impfzentren bürger testungen
arzneimittel schutz von
versorgungsstrukturen
ausgleichszahlungen das ist alles geld
was sinnvoll eingesetzt das muss ja auch
gesagt wenn wir verschwenden nichts wir
verhandeln hat die habe das ist das geld
was das gesundheitssystem auch braucht
und das ist insgesamt insbesondere auch
das geld was die krankenhäuser brauchen
denn die krankenhäuser tragen den
schwersten teil der last der versorgung
dieser patienten sagt mehr als zwei
jahren ihnen gebührt mein besonderer
dank insbesondere den pflegekräften aber
auch den ersten grund was man viel zu
wenig wird auch den vielen menschen die
ihnen diesen krankenhäusern arbeiten und
den betrieb am laufen halten das sind
diejenigen denen sie hier danken das
sind diejenigen zu live im mittel zur
verfügung drin
auch die gesetzliche krankenversicherung
hat massive einnahmenrückgänge gehabt
natürlich wegen der wirtschaftlichen
entwicklung wir füttern das war wir
unterstützen das mit 14 milliarden euro
zuerst die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung weiter funktionieren
kann für all den ich auch die erkranken
und die die hilfe brauchen die von
kubicki nicht betroffen sind wir haben
darüber hinaus zwei formen von kosten
die viel zu selten erwähnt werden aber
die in einer haushaltsrede auch erwähnt
werden müssen weil sie da sind weil es
hohe kosten sind das sind zum einen die
kosten die diejenigen tragen die anlage
wieder erkannt sind diejenigen die an
langen kurven erkannten verlieren nicht
nur ihre produkte für die wirtschaft
ihrer produktivität sondern ihre
lebensqualität verändert sich oft von
heute auf morgen und von dem was wir
jetzt wissen auf unbestimmte zeit longo
wird wird zu den wichtigsten chronischen
erkrankungen in deutschland gehören und
zwar insbesondere auch bei denjenigen
der mittleren lebensphase das können wir
nicht akzeptiert schon alleine deshalb
müssen wir gegen die hohe intelligenz
ankämpfen und ich möchte ihnen
ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen es ist die
impfung die auch von longo fidan
sichersten schutz wir haben gott sei
dank ist klarer hinweis darauf dass das
longo witt risiko wenn man ihn sich
infiziert aber geimpft ist dass das
longboard risiko deutlich reduziert ist
und das ist etwas was wir sagen das sind
vor allem wir appellieren müssen bis zur
heute ebene der kosten der welt wenn
muss sie auch immer wieder zu kurz kommt
das sind diejenigen die die geistingen
die seelischen kosten tragen das sind
diejenigen deren hochzeit abgesagt wurde
der
feier abgesagt wurde ein geburtstag
nicht gefeiert wird konto wenn es der
letzte geburtstag zum tage gewesen die
menschen haben ihren letzten geburtstag
nicht mehr fallen können die
bildungschancen die verloren sind die
kinder die opfer gebracht haben die ihre
freunde nicht besuchen können die
älteren menschen die in den letzten
lebensjahren ihre menschen nicht mehr
sehen konnte auch ihnen schulden wir
dass wir diese pandemie beenden und es
gibt einen weg diese pandemie zu
entgehen sie diesen weg mit mir der weg
der weg aus der familie heraus der weg
aus dem haus was wir jedes mal ist die
allgemeine impfpflicht war mit der fluke
die wir jetzt haben werden wir im herbst
die gleiche debatte für und die es
führen wir werden das land gehören
erneut haben reicht das
infektionsschutzgesetz aus wir werden
die debatte haben was müssen wir
schließen müssen die kinder masken
tragen die gesamte debatte sie kommt
erneut der einzige zuverlässige weg aus
der panne mehr heraus ist die allgemeine
impfpflicht es ist auch der weg den die
gruppe der größte teil der bevölkerung
will ich glaube es auch der weg den der
größte teil des bundestags somit nehmen
wir uns doch die kraft beenden wir die
pandemie in diesem jahr wir haben es in
der hand wir können in diesem jahr die
pandemie beenden und wir sollten diese
gaben die impfstoffe wir wissen welche
varianten im herbst mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit zu erwarten sind wird
wir dürfen nicht warten hier appelliere
ich ausdrücklich auch an die union ich
weiß dass in der union viele sind eher
frei ich weiß dass in der union viele
sind bei ihnen nicht rechts von ihnen
bei ihnen sind viele die im prinzip die
allgemeine impfpflicht richtig finde und
mitgehen ich hab einfach an sie wir
dürfen es nicht verschieben wenn wir zu
spät anfangen was ihr vorschlag ist
unbenommen nicht in jedem punkt falsch
auch wenn wir zu spät beginnen mit der
endlich sein haben wir die impfpflicht
erst durchgezogen für das nächste
frühjahr das kommt an zu spät bedenken
sie auch die hohen wirtschaftlichen
kosten denken sie an die enttäuschung
die ich zu erwarten wäre werden wir das
nicht schaffen ich weiß dass wir
miteinander verhandeln müssen habe ich
appelliere an alle die hier vernünftig
sind das können wir gemeinsam bewältigen
die impfpflicht ist was wir brauchen
sonst drehen wir uns im kreis herum und
beenden die tante mimi in diesem jahr
nicht dass lehrer eine verlorene
gelegenheit die wir nicht wieder
bekommen werden
und ich möchte mich an die ungeimpften
direkt noch einmal wenden ich möchte
mich an die ungeimpften direkten
verwendet nutzen sie wenigstens eine
impfung in diesen tagen denn mit einer
impfung reduzieren sich schon deutlich
sieben tage nach der impfung ihr risiko
intensivmedizinisch versorgt zu werden
oder sogar zu sterben noch nie war das
risiko noch niemals das risiko für die
ungeimpften so hoch sich zu infizieren
und schwer zu erkranken ein großer teil
der 300 menschen die jetzt pro tag
versterben sind ungeimpfte daher
appelliere ich an die umgebung tun sie
sich selbst den größten gefallen die
sich durch dann nächstes schlimmer als
in den letzten tagen bevor der sommer
kommt und wie eine pause bekommen noch
schwer zu erkranken oder gar zu
versterben nutzen sie die gelegenheit
die wir ihnen bieten sich dagegen
karl lauterbach mit einem ja fast
flehentlichen appel
die noch nicht geimpft sind oder gar
gepostete sich impfen zu lassen er sagte
nur so kommen wir aus der premiere aus
über impfungen sonst werde sich im hatte
die bewährte sich im herbst spätestens
die debatte über einschränkungen
wiederholen ohne und ja und ein ganz
wichtiger punkt sei eben auch das logo
wird möglicherweise in absehbarer zeit
zu einer der häufigsten chronischen
erkrankungen werde das antwortet kino
sorge der gesundheitspolitische sprecher
der unions-fraktion und wir sind
trotzdem parat für das statement der
drei parteivorsitzenden
ich sehe unruhe und wir müssen raus aus
dem bundestag an dieser stelle denn
jetzt gibt es die ergebnisse vom
koalitionsausschuss zu entlastungen für
die bürgerinnen und bürger in unserem
land
leiden unter den massiv steigenden
energiepreisen das ist zweifelsohne und
deshalb kann man ja sagen dass
haushaltsdebatten auch immer eine
möglichkeit sind was ganz besonderes
also wir debattieren über grundsätzliche
fragen aber im vergleich zu dem was die
ampel was auch sie sich in den letzten
tagen wieder geleistet haben ist das
hier überhaupt nichts also
widersprüchliche aussagen des
bundesgesundheitsministers bei der frage
finanzierung des gesundheitssystems also
da gibt es dann ein referentenentwurf
der öffentlich publik wird einen tag
später sagen sie ist gäbe gar keinen
entwurf zur finanzierung gkv finanz
stabilisierungs gesetzes deshalb lieber
bundesgesundheitsminister machen sie
endlich ernst bessere kommunikation
hatten sie versprochen hatten sie
angekündigt davon ist leider nichts zu
sehen vielleicht klappt das ja in den
nächsten wochen und monaten mal wieder
besser liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir müssen sie ja auch wieder
konstatieren dass offensichtlich diese
einigkeit in der ampel so nicht besteht
wenn dann der bundesgesundheitsminister
verkündet bei der frage wie deckt er die
finanzierungslücke im bereich der gkv
das sei damit dem kanzler abgesprochen
das sei mit dem grundgesetz
bundesfinanzminister abgestorben und
einen tag später der
bundesfinanzminister lindner sagt das
seien individuelle vorstellung des
kollegen lauterbach und da kann ich nur
sagen wenn dann auch noch der
finanzstaatssekretär sagt man warte
erstmal die ergebnisse des
schätzerkreises im herbst es ab dann
kann ich nur sagen wer so
widersprüchlich finanzplanung betreibt
wird keinen erfolg haben und noch viel
schlimmer wäre solche kabinettskollegen
hat der braucht wahrlich keine
opposition liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und es scheint ja mittlerweile schon zum
guten ton zu gehören das auch innerhalb
des bundeskabinetts es ihre vorstöße
lieber herr bundesgesundheitsminister
nur noch für schulterzucken
zu schulterzucken führen beim
infektionsschutzgesetzes haben sie den
bundesjustizminister überrascht bei der
frage der der hot spots beim gkv finanz
stabilisierungs gesetzes ausgerechnet
den finanzminister und er sucht dann
kann ich nur sagen finanzierung des
gesundheitssystems ist eine teamaufgabe
und diese teamaufgabe die sollten sie
auch in der ampelkoalition erfüllen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ich
würde ja auch mal was positives sagen
aber wenn ich mir ganz objektiv die
fakten anschaut dann kann man bisher
sagen jedes einzelne projekt der ampel
ist ein flop ich sage ihnen auch warum
pandemie lage im november in die del
tabelle hinein abgeschafft genießen den
status chaos mit ansage deutscher
sonderweg alle europäischen länder
machen was anderes finanzstabilisierungs
gesetz auf eis gelegt allgemeine
impfpflicht entgegen ihrer behauptungen
die sich ihr auch stellen keine mehrheit
im parlament
infektionsschutzgesetz ging haarscharf
am koalitionsbruch vorbei triage entwurf
arbeitsverweigerung offene
arbeitsverweigerung gegenüber dem
bundesverfassungsgericht und
letztendlich das darf ich eben oder das
kann ich ihnen leider auch nicht
durchgehen lassen sie stellen sich
hierhin loben die pflegekräfte loben die
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter im
medizinischen systeme gesundheitssystem
seit über vier monaten warten die auf
den corona bonus für die mfs für die zfs
jetzt machen sie endlich ernst mit den
ankündigungen die haben den antrag
gestellt stimmen sie diesen antrag zu
dass wir diese wertschätzung auch
tatsächlich konkret den
menschen vor ort zeit und
die liste die wird ja immer länger das
schlimme an der ganzen situation ist ja
dass man sich hier vorkommt wie der
japaner oder täglich grüßt das
murmeltier
wir haben vor wochen schon sie gebeten
dass sie auch als bmw x einer vorhaben
planung vorlegen sie sind mittlerweile
über 100 tagen an es gibt keine konkrete
vorhaben planung es gibt keine planung
welche vorhaben sie wann die in welcher
zeitschiene umsetzen wollen und bei dem
was sie sagen kann man sich bei der
halbwertszeit ja leider nicht wirklich
darauf verlassen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und weil wir bei den problemen sind
hätte ich mir schon gewünscht dass sie
hier auch mal ein punkte dazu sagen wie
es bei den krankenkassen finanzen weiter
gehen sollte wie es im herbst weitergeht
und insbesondere wie es bei der
pflegeversicherung weitergehen soll sie
vertragen die frage der auskömmlichen
finanzierung der pflegeversicherung in
eine kommission 20 23 sie geben keine
perspektive bei der frage der
krankenhauslandschaft und ich kann ihnen
sagen diese aufschieberitis wird ihnen
auf die füße fällt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der ampelkoalition und deshalb
deshalb kommen sie kommen sie jetzt auch
nicht mit dem argument wer in den
letzten jahren regiert hat auch die
kolleginnen der spd und das ich will uns
das jetzt alles erspart aber was sich
bemerkenswert finde ist dass die ampel
für 20 23 in der haushaltsplan und meine
kolleginnen und kollegen werden dazu je
nach konkreter was sagen den etat des
bmg um zwei drittel kürzen und da frage
ich sie allen ernstes ist das genau die
wertschätzung die sie den
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums ist dass
die wertschätzung die sie dem
gesundheitssystem entgegenbringen die
sie hier immer proklamieren das ist
fahrlässig das gesundheitsressort spart
am falschen ende liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deshalb lassen sie mir zum
schluss lieber herr
bundesgesundheitsminister noch sagen sie
haben vor einigen tagen ihren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern einen
brief geschrieben in dem sie nach 100
tagen im amt gedankt haben sie haben
geschrieben dass sie den beschäftigten
für die arbeit im ausnahmezustand
ausdrücklich danken das ist richtig sie
haben gleichzeitig aber auch darauf
hingewiesen
dass letztendlich die arbeitsbelastung
also der permanente ausnahmezustand im
arbeitsalltag zu vermeiden sein sollte
und deshalb kann ich leider nur sagen
wenn sie das getan hätten was sie sagen
dann hätten sie keine kürzung von 65%
des bmg etats bereits im entwurfsstadium
zugelassen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deshalb meine bitte die
bitte unserer fraktion lassen sie sich
bei den haushaltsberatungen nicht vom
bundesgesundheitsminister über den tisch
ziehen sprechen sie vorher mit den
kolleginnen und kollegen dass das was
ich ankündigen tatsächlich auch
sinngrund mit dem geht was sie dann
tatsächlich machen vielen dank liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
vielen dank herr sorge
und wir kommen jetzt für bündnis 90 die
grünen zur kollegin dr paul j
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrter
herr lauterbach
corona ist nicht vorbei das stimmt und
dieser satz wird er jetzt gerade immer
mantraartig wiederholt weil bestimmte
kolleginnen kollegen das auch nicht
verstehen wollen aber eher verdeckt ja
schon so ein stück weit dass die
pandemie sich doch deutlich verändert
hat in den letzten ein bisschen mehr als
zwei jahren und deswegen würde ich sie
gern noch mal kurz mit in das erste jahr
der korona pandemie nehmen da war ich
nicht hier da war ich in der klinik
selber
und da war ist tatsächlich so dass wir
sehr viel damit zu tun hatten das uns in
der klinik alle masken geklaut wurden
und nie desinfektionsmittel da bist
überall sicherheitsdienste standen dann
gab es irgendwann das problem dass man
nicht mehr musste wusste welche
patienten darf man jetzt noch behandeln
welche nicht permanent fehlten kollegen
in den dienstplänen und angeblich zu da
hat man die debatten hier im bundestag
wirklich nur aus den augenwinkeln
wahrgenommen aber das was man mit
bekommen hat war da wurde geklotzt und
nicht gekleckert
da war für alles geld da und es war auch
unglaublich spannend zu sehen obwohl wir
alle immer wieder darauf hingewiesen
haben dass
klinikbetten alleine noch keine
patienten versorgen können dass
beatmungsgeräte allein noch keine
patienten versorgen können das dass der
ganz große schwerpunkt in den corona
beschaffungen und zusatzausgaben der
ersten monate war und es war das war
tatsächlich ich sage dass deswegen weil
das was mit den beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen gemacht hat wenn wir
unglaublich viele lücken im dienstplan
hast und du kommst abends zum
nachtdienst und läufst vor bei einem
flur der volle betten steht in
originalverpackung die mit boni der
bundesregierung beschafft wurden ohne
dass sie jemals in benutzung gehen
würden und du gehst da hin und du siehst
das geld ist da aber es ist kein kollege
da der mit dir zusammen nach dienst ist
dann macht das was mit ihr weil es dir
zeit da wären die falschen prioritäten
gesetzt und wenn du morgens um nach dem
aus der klinik raus kommst du fährst
nach hause und als die krone teststation
du weißt ganz genau dafür dienstgrad ihm
eine goldene nase aber an den
tarifverträgen in der klinik hat sich
nichts geändert das macht was mit den
leuten die im gesundheitswesen arbeiten
und deswegen reicht es nicht den heute
danke zu sagen sondern wir müssen jetzt
in diese phase kommen wo wir auch die
arbeitsbedingungen im gesundheitswesen
dramatisch verbessern und dafür brauchen
wir auch jeden euro aber wir haben die
punkte
liegen
und er ist einfach unglaublich viel
schief gelaufen das wissen wir alle und
deswegen müssen wir heute auch
kritischer darauf schauen es wurde viel
geld mit vollen händen ausgegeben masken
beschaffung corona teststation diese
betten zuschüsse auf 50.000 euro ssp
masken ausgabe über die apotheken das
unglaublich viel schief gelaufen und das
muss jetzt vorbei sein ja wir wollen
kröner beenden und wir wollen alles was
notwendig ist in dieser krise
ausfinanzieren aber wenn wir jetzt
kritisch auf alles drauf schauen was
auch jetzt wieder im einzelfall
drinsteht dann ist es nicht weil wir
corona nicht beenden wollen sondern das
ist wahr wir wissen dass die dass die
mittel in diesem etat jeder euro den man
da dafür finden kann dass die
gesundheitsbedingungen und die
arbeitsbedingungen der beschäftigten
sich verbessern und auch die
patientenversorgung dass die dort noch
besser aufgehoben sind das ist der
einzige grund warum wir so kritische und
ich glaube im dritten jahr der korona
pandemie muss man das auch erreichen
können
und der kommt ja auch so ein bisschen
zum grundproblem weil eigentlich sollten
wir ja in der haushaltsdebatte meinem
einzelplan 15 sollten wir gar nicht so
viel ausgaben kritik an der gkv machen
aber warum müssen wir das machen wir
jetzt quasi eine teilweise
steuerfinanzierten gesetzliche
krankenversicherung haben und es wir
sind als grüne fans der
bürgerversicherung habe zum teil
steuerfinanziertes versicherungskonzept
das ist nicht unsere idee dass teilweise
1 der vermächtnisse von jens spahn
gesundheitsministerium und da müssen wir
ganz schnell wieder davon wegkommen aber
wenn das jetzt gerade so ist und es tut
ja gerade so aus als ob dass er immer
weiter geht wenn es gerade so ist dann
ist es nur folgerichtig dass auch das
bundesfinanzministerium damit in den
schätzerkreis rein genommen werden muss
und dann ist auch noch folgerichtig dass
auch der haushaltsausschuss und die
aufgabenkritik der gkv einsteigen muss
aber ich halte es nicht für ideal schon
allein weil dann kollegen wie hermann
trade mit darüber entscheiden den
schlimmsten fall was im gkv system noch
finanziert und was nicht nichts gegen
kollegen mattfeldt aber das ist keine
ideale lösung
naja das zurzeit mit halt
[Applaus]
und ich habe jetzt ungefähr dreimal
betont wie wichtig bessere
arbeitsbedingungen im gesundheitswesen
sind und natürlich gibt es in diesem
etat entwurf den corona bonus da steht
eine milliarde drin man kann das machen
aber sollte sich niemand der illusion
hingeben dass und wir hatten ja schon
corona boni in der vergangenheit
deswegen sonnenkorona bonus jemand der
nach fünf nach diensten in folge völlig
ausgebrannt ist und sich fragt ob er in
dieser art und weise ich diesen beruf in
vollzeit bis zur rente durch steht
deswegen dem corona bonus irgendjemand
nicht in teilzeit geht oder irgendjemand
zusätzlich im beruf bleibt und auch
deswegen ist es wieder ja man kann das
machen aber die frage ist ja was hätten
wir mit dieser milliarde gegebenenfalls
auch eine verbesserung für die
arbeitsbedingungen
ja die pandemie ist nicht vorbei aber
die zeit der wenig zielgerichtet in
corona maßnahmen und der verschwendung
bei den kassen am haus vorbei sein und
wir brauchen jetzt ein sehr gute
kommunikation zwischen
haushaltsausschuss und dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium
damit wir in eine sehr gute gemeinsame
grundlage dafür kommen was wir in diesem
dritten jahr der korona pandemie
zielgerichtet finanzieren können und was
nicht denn wir brauchen jeden euro den
wir da zusätzlich finden können für eine
echte zukunftsfeste aufstellung unseres
gesundheitswesens das hat echt auf dem
zahnfleisch geht wir brauchen mehr
mittel für eine echte prävention und 30
jetzt noch mal die punkte an die im
koalitionsvertrag stehe und dass alle
gehörten noch nicht im haushalt des
ministeriums abbilden
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fraktion die linke ich gehe daher auch
die kollegen zu und würde jetzt einfach
schnell ganz zum entwicklung
viel sorge ich komme auch gerne zu ihnen
passt nämlich
wir brauchen jeden euro für eine echte
neue präventionsstrategie und drei
sicherheit die punkte an die alle noch
nicht ausfinanziert im einzelplan ihre
im koalitionsvertrag stehen wir brauchen
auch jeden euro für verbesserungen der
arbeitsbedingungen die dringend
notwendig sind in dieser situation und
wir brauchen auch jeden euro und da
spreche jetzt auch als eine vertreterin
aus sachsen für die sicherung der
medizinischen versorgung und
pflegerischen versorgung im überalterten
ländlichen raum darüber hat hier heute
noch niemand gesprochen auch das wird
eine herkulesaufgabe auch rassist noch
nicht ausreichend abgebildet und auch
das wäre mir die nächsten finden die
vier jahren aus finanzieren müssen
vielen dank
vielen dank frau kollegin
erhält das wort für die afg fraktion der
abgeordnete wolfgang viele
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist ein
unterschied ob man politik für die
gesundheit macht oder ob man mit
krankheit politik macht
es ist ein unterschied ob man im
angesicht neuartiger gesundheitsgefahren
über das richtige verhalten aufklärt und
das nötige organisiert oder ob man den
menschen angst macht um sich
anschließend als der große retter in
szene zu setzen
es ist ein unterschied ob man gegen neue
erreger impfstoffe entwickelt diese
getestet und sie den menschen anbietet
oder ob man sie den menschen aufzwingt
ohne rücksicht auf deren persönliche
entscheidung und deren grundrecht
dieser unterschied macht sich auch im
haushalt bemerkbar andere länder wie
schweden wusste ich keine regierung als
retter aus hochgepuscht angst
aufgespielt hat sind wirtschaftlich viel
besser durch die krise gekommen das ist
freilich ein thema für andere
einzelpläne dieses bundeshaushalts aber
auch der einzelplan 15 zeigt eine
deutliche aufblähung
der haushalt des gesundheitsministeriums
ist mit über 52 milliarden euro so groß
wie nie zuvor und das obwohl der
höhepunkt der korona krise hinter uns
liegt die gründe dafür liegen in der
völlig verfehlten impfkampagne
so hatte die bundesregierung bereits vor
einigen wochen
677 millionen impfstoffdosen bestellt
teilt man das durch die anzahl der
bundesbürger rund 83 millionen so ergibt
dass mehr als acht impfstoff dosen pro
kopf vom säugling bis zum greis bei
einer quote von 100 prozent
auch wenn viel impfstoff an
entwicklungsländer verschenkt wird zeigt
das klar diese bundesregierung rechnet
mit einem dauer booster zwangs abo für
alle deutschen
[Applaus]
kurz vor weihnachten hatte der einkauf
und kurbelt impfstoffen bereits rund
vier milliarden euro verschlungen und
für dieses jahr sind nun über sechs
milliarden angesetzt
millionen bundesbürger haben sich aber
in ihrer persönlichen nutzen risiko
abwägung gegen die impfung entschieden
das hat ganz offensichtlich mit den
teils massiven nebenwirkungen der
impfstoffe zu tun auch wenn diese
offiziell immer noch geleugnet werden
die regierung inszeniert deshalb eine
regelrechte werbematerial schlacht der
haushaltsansatz für
öffentlichkeitsarbeit beträgt
215 millionen euro nach gut fünf
millionen euro im letzten jahr das ist
das 40 fache
wir alle wissen dass es auch mit der
werbe schlacht nicht gelungen ist die
menschen in unserem land zu überzeugen
deshalb wird er jetzt über den zwang wir
endlich debattiert und damit das
vertrauen vieler bürger in den staat für
jahrzehnte aufs spiel gesetzt
[Applaus]
weitere 2,8 milliarden euro sollen in
den kommenden jahren in sogenannte
pandemie bereitschafts verträge fließen
pharmaunternehmen bekommen dieses geld
damit sie kapazitäten vorhalten und
innerhalb von drei monaten die
produktion von impfstoffen hochfranken
nur welches vakzin meine damen und
herren es innerhalb von drei monaten
entwickelt und getestet
natürlich kann man experimentelle
impfstoffe anbieten aber eins muss dabei
ein für alle mal tabu sein nämlich eine
impfpflicht
[Applaus]
diese und weitere ausgabeposten werden
den nächsten wochen gelegenheit
intensiver diskussionen seien auf eins
können sich die deutschen verlassen die
afg wird nie mit krankheit politik
machen und die alv level immer auf der
seite der freiheit stehen
[Applaus]
vielen dank
nunmehr erhält das wort für die
fdp-fraktion der kollege karsten klein
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich will zu
beginn auch erst mal alle menschen in
diesem land danken die jetzt in der
korona krise die einschränkungen
mitgetragen haben gehofft haben dass das
virus sich nicht weiter verbreiten kann
die an die eingriffe ertragen mussten
und vor allem möchte ich mich natürlich
und stellvertretend bei denen bedanken
die im gesundheitssystem gearbeitet
haben und gearbeitet und dort arbeiten
die pflegerinnen und pfleger aber auch
die vielen helfenden kräfte die deren
arbeit möglich machen und
ich möchte mich ganz besonders auch bei
den menschen bedanken die für sich
selbst und für andere verantwortung
übernommen haben und sich impfen lassen
haben impfen ist der schlüssel um diese
pandemie zu bekämpfen und zu beenden und
deshalb ist es richtig dass die sich am
impfen lassen und deshalb nochmal ganz
herzlichen dank auch an dieser stelle
drei monate lang jeweils neun euro im
monat für ein ticket eine energiepreis
pauschale von 300 euro im monat eine
einmalzahlung für kinder von 1 100 euro
also da kommt eine menge geld zusammen
den betrag machte christian ist da eben
noch nicht spezifizieren oder
detailliert sagen weil ja natürlich
nachricht ich weiß wie viele
beispielsweise dieses
ticket in anspruch nehmen werden und
welche weiteren unwägbarkeiten da
möglicherweise noch kaum jedenfalls ein
großes paket was vielen nützen und
dürften gespannt auf die diskussion die
in kürze einsetzen wird zum gleichen
thema und jahre ja super noch gefunden
werden was die abwicklung beispielsweise
angeht und ähnliches oder auch wie sehr
das ganze teil des ergänzungs haushalt
wird und auf welche art und weise also
da gibt es jetzt im beschluss der
koalition aber dass ich noch nicht das
ende der diskussion wir blicken zurück
ins plenum da wird diskutiert über den
etat des
bundesgesundheitsministers und wir sehen
am pult karsten klein die ideen und man
der fdp fraktion im haushaltsausschuss
vor allem nicht für die die hier die
letzten vier jahre saßen denn wir wissen
alle dass die spanische gesetzgebung ja
nach berechnungen der krankenkassen
allein für über 12 milliarden euro
kostensteigerungen sorgt alles ist ein
problem auf dass wir zu gelaufen sind
und dass uns die vorgängerregierung ja
sozusagen mit auf den weg gegeben hat
und deshalb finde ich sollten alle die
so kräftig nachzahlen fragen einfach mal
eine interne diskussion starten da kann
man vielleicht einiges lernen
herr minister sie haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass der bund in dieser
pandemie sehr kraftvoll finanziell auch
agiert hat und nach wie vor agiert
allein in den zwei haushaltstiteln wie
die ausgleichzahlungen im
krankenhauswesen und für die leistungen
im gesundheitsfonds die zusätzlichen
leistungen im gesundheitsfonds werden
aktuell 26,3 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt
12,5 milliarden euro haben wir für das
thema testen in den letzten monaten
bereitgestellt
1,5 milliarden euro stehen noch mal für
das impfen drin ich will einfach nur
darauf hinweisen dass wir ja natürlich
und es war auch richtig in der krise
kraftvoll agiert haben aber ich will an
der stelle schon noch mal die frage
stellen und die wird in den nächsten
wochen auch im hinblick auf diesem
defizit intensiv zu diskutieren sein
welche rolle eigentlich die händler und
welt ob die länder ihrer verantwortung
bei der finanzierung im
gesundheitssystem und bei solchen
pandemien überhaupt gerecht werden wir
haben für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst einen pakt geschlossen
wo der bund 4 milliarden euro zur
verfügung stellt für eine ureigenste
aufgabe der länder und dass wir nicht in
der lage sind über moderne technologien
in dieser pandemie zu kommunizieren
dafür tragen die länder die
verantwortung dass wir gefaxt haben in
einem hoch technik land bei so einer
pandemie dafür tragen die länder die
verantwortung des wehrs längst an der
zeit jetzt nicht nur einzugestehen
sondern endlich auch eigene finanzielle
mittel und kraftvoll dagegen zu wirken
der bund hat darüber hinaus im bereich
der digitalisierung der krankenhäuser 3
milliarden euro zur verfügung gestellt
70 prozent der investitionen in die
digitalisierung übernimmt bei diesen
projekten der bund nicht dass sie mich
falsch verstehen ich finde die
digitalisierung im gesundheitssystem
zentral wichtig auch gerade in den
krankenhäusern krankenhäuser und da
besteht auch ein großer nachholbedarf
aber es zeigt doch eklatant wie die
länder ihrer verantwortung nicht gerecht
werden der bundesrechnungshof hat in
seinem bericht noch einmal festgestellt
dass die länder pro jahr eine
finanzierungs investitionslücke von vier
milliarden euro die pro jahr vier
milliarden euro entstehen lassen weil
sie ihre verpflichtungen nicht
nachkommen in die krankenhaus
infrastruktur in die gebäude die
entsprechenden mittel zur verfügung zu
stellen 4 milliarden euro und das sind
nicht nur investitionsmittel die
vielleicht an ein krankenhaus
infrastruktur herstellen sondern da geht
es auch um die kosten im betrieb der
krankenhäuser denn veraltete strukturen
führen dazu dass eben keine moderne
technik eingesetzt werden kann die sorgt
dafür dass wir keine modernen prozesse
und abläufe durchführen können und die
belasten die krankenkassen in den
betriebskosten und damit letztendlich
auch den bundeszuschuss und damit den
bundeshaushalt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und deshalb will ich an der
stelle herr minister sie noch mal
auffordern es ist leider in der letzten
legislaturperiode verschlafen worden
aber wir müssen das kaffeegeschirr
mit den ländern endlich mal zur seite
stellen der kraftvolle pressekonferenzen
gibt der sollte auch kraftvoll agieren
wo er in verantwortung ist und das
gehört zur wahrheit auch mit dazu
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
glaube dass wir beim thema
bundeszuschuss bei der frage wie die bei
krankenkassen beiträge in der
pflegeversicherung austariert werden
auch noch mal klar machen sollten die
kollegin piotta hat es gerade sehr gut
schon formuliert es wird immer mehr auch
der bundeszuschuss hier in die debatte
mit eingebracht und deshalb ist es auch
aufgabe hier im deutschen bundestag über
diese finanzierung zu sprechen auf jeden
fall sollte man wenn man über
aufteilungen und kostenbelastungen
nachdenkt diesen diesen bundestag und
dem vor allem dem haushaltsausschuss und
den gesundheitsausschuss auch mit
einbeziehen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
kassen klein war das mitglied im
haushalt obmann im haushaltsausschuss
für die fdp-fraktion im bundestag
diskutiert weiter über dem etat des
bundesgesundheitsministers das spielt
natürlich immer mal wieder das thema
corona und pandemie bekämpfung eine
rolle aber im moment sind die haushälter
gefragt also wie die sich wirklich mit
dem geld beschäftigen die sie nutzen
lädt zum beispiel für die linksfraktion
und bundesminister lauterbach forderte
gesundheit muss einen neuen und größeren
stellenwert in der gesellschaft bekommt
das ist richtig doch woher lauterbach
bildet sich das im bundeshaushalt ab wir
haben es nicht gefunden meine damen und
herren
stellen wir uns auch nur einmal drei
minuten vor aus dem sondervermögen
bundeswehr wird ein sondervermögen
gesundheit was könnten wir mit 100
milliarden euro alles erreichen wir
könnten verhindern dass die
krankenkassenbeiträge weiter steigen sie
dagegen wollen die beiträge noch vor der
sommerpause erhöhen das ist falsch das
leben gehabt haben
wir können endlich unsere krankenhäuser
sanieren die linke hat in den
vergangenen jahren immer wieder ein
krankenhaus investitionsprogramm von 50
milliarden euro über zehn jahre
gefordert die hälfte müssten natürlich
die länder tragen oder stellen sich vor
der bundeskanzler eröffnet statt einer
neuen autofabrik mal eine neue
geburtsklinik oder eine kinderstation
stadt das welche geschlossen werden
oder an meine damen und herren wir
nutzen das geld für eine grundlegende
reform des gesundheitswesens wir führen
endlich die bürgerversicherung einen
dann müssten die menschen nicht mehr
monate auf einen termin beim facharzt
warten und wir schaffen endlich die
absurden fallpauschalen ab wir schreiben
dann ins grundgesetz zum thema
gesundheit gesundheit ist keine ware
jeder mensch hat das recht auf eine gute
krankenversorgung wagen sie endlich
fortschritt oder wir starten eine
kampagne wie die bundeswehr es getan hat
aber stattdessen suchen der pflegekräfte
die für arbeit auch gut bezahlt werden
ein cdu abgeordneter twitterte kürzlich
es muss allen klar sein zitat das die
bundeswehr grundvoraussetzung für unser
leben ist naja ich sage
grundvoraussetzung für das leben ist
erst eine mutter und eine hebamme meine
damen und herren eine umfrage unter
anderem stellten klinik hebammen ergab
dass 90 prozent der befragten
überstunden leisten müssen und keine
pause machen können und die hälfte der
heber betreuten drei frauen parallel das
ist doch nicht zu fassen das muss sich
ändern meine damen und herren wir
brauchen also völlig unabhängig von
corona aber corona ist ja noch eins
draufgesetzt wir brauchen endlich gute
arbeitsbedingungen im gesundheitswesen
wir brauchen für die menschen die in der
pflege arbeiten aber auch alle die in
den krankenhaus arbeiten zu ärzten und
ärzte aber auch die für die logistik
zuständig sind zuverlässige
tarifverträge gute bezahlung und vor
allen dingen arbeitszeiten die auch das
leben für diese menschen lebenswert
gesine lötzsch stellvertretende
vorsitzende der linksfraktion und
haushaltspolitische sprecherin hat jetzt
sich nicht nur über zahlen geäußert
sondern auch über schwerpunkte wie sie
sich vorstellen kann im sektor
gesundheitswesen svenja stadt leiste die
nächste rednerin sie kommt aus der spd
fraktion und mitglied im
haushaltsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin lieber
gesundheitsminister lauterbach sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
die krankenhaus- und
gesundheitsversorgung ist eine zentrale
säule
unserer sicherheit wenn wir doch im
alltag plötzlich das im alltag
interessen werben durch den unfall oder
durch ein burnout oder einfach nur durch
eine erkältung dann wissen wir werden
wir aufgefangen manchmal ist dann eine
stationäre betreuung ganz ratsam und der
einen oder anderen stelle hilft auch
eine kur oder eben doch auch einfach nur
medikamente aus der apotheke von nebenan
und wir wissen doch egal ob diese
behandlung 1000 euro kostet oder auch
nur ein euro wir werden in dieser
situation einfach nicht alleine gelassen
und jetzt
müssen wir aber doch genauer hinschauen
wir müssen genauer hinschauen auf unser
gesundheitssystem denn lange wird es das
nicht mehr schaffen die krankenhäuser
versicherung
pflegeeinrichtungen und all die anderen
zusätzlichen player in diesem großen
system sind für uns eine
selbstverständlichkeit
doch es ist immer deutlicher dass eben
diese sicherheit nicht mehr
selbstverständlich ist es fehlen die
fachkräfte doch in den krankenhäusern
und in den pflegeeinrichtungen unter
anderen wir nehmen doch war das
apotheken mehr und mehr schließen weil
die nachfolge einfach nicht geregelt ist
oder gerade in den ländlichen räumen
doch die ärzteversorgung nach und nach
wirklich zu wünschen übrig lässt und
jetzt kommt die digitalisierung dazu die
digitalisierung damit treten auch neue
sucht potenziale auf oder eben auch
körperliche belastungen in den
unterschiedlichsten altersgruppen die
müssen wir begegnen und gleichzeitig ist
die digitalisierung die chance für das
gesundheitswesen gar keine frage und
eben nicht nur um bürokratie abzubauen
und dann gibt es noch die älteren
menschen und die die auch lange krank
sind jeglicher weise die wollen aber
auch sehr lange zu hause bleiben und da
brauchen wir ein flexibles handeln im
gesundheitssektor anders ist es nicht
möglich und all das was vor jahren
vielleicht funktioniert hat ist heute
veraltet kann nicht mehr funktionieren
weil es längst überholt ist und dann
müssen wir uns doch selbstkritisch
dieser frage stellen dass wir eben nicht
effektiv gehandelt haben in der
vergangenheit dass wir die falschen wege
genommen haben weil wir nicht selten
zielorientierte entscheidungen getroffen
haben und ja und da stimme ich ein klein
zu auch die bundesländer haben nicht
ihre bahn ihrer verantwortung nicht
gerecht und die dürfen da auch einiges
tun und momentan und das finde ich
dürften wir auch noch mal bei uns
anschauen behandeln wir doch die
probleme die sich so auf tun die
krankheiten oder wir lindern doch nur
die symptome nehmen wir doch den
bundeszuschuss einmal wenn wir stabil
halten oder wollten auf 14,5 milliarden
euro nehmen wir immer wieder dem
gesundheitsfonds zu geben doch nun
stocken wir abermals auf und dieses mal
zusätzlich um 21 7 milliarden euro damit
schließen wir auf einen und der einen
seite die lücke bei der gesetzlichen
kranken finanzierung versicherungs
finanzierung und auf der anderen seite
decken wir aber die kosten aus dem
pandemischen versorgen ein brauchen wir
nicht
leistungen die bürger test versorgungs
ausschlag für kranken
arzneimittel und eben auch den
schutzmasken und diesen
herausforderungen übrigens ja sorge
begegnen wir indem wir nämlich die
gesundheitsfinanzierung weiterentwickeln
wollen und wissen sie schauen sie
einfach im koalitionsvertrag das hilft
lesen hilft wer es kam
es wird die zeit
denn es wird zeit endlich auch die
ursachen wir müssen uns mit diesen
ursachen befassen die grundlegenden
probleme in diesem system doch erkennen
und dann die richtigen weichen stellen
denn nur so gelingt es uns doch dieses
gesundheitssystem endlich
zukunftstauglich zu machen das ist nicht
einfach und es bedeutet auch harte
auseinandersetzung mit all den plan in
diesem system
aber es ist wichtig die ausstattung in
vielen krankenhäusern ist weit entfernt
von dem was möglich sein könnte deshalb
ist es richtig die nötigen reformen auf
den weg zu bringen dass sie modern und
eine bedarfsgerechte
krankenhausversorgung eben auf den weg
bringen können der technologische
fortschritt ist der schlüssel zu mehr
effizienz der alltag der ist nämlich
damit vereinfacht krankheit mit besseren
methoden können wir damit begegnen und
mehr krisensicherheit auch schaffen mit
187 millionen euro stärken wir deshalb
die forschung davon fließen alleine
54,2 millionen digitalisierung und
innovation im gesundheitswesen damit
werden wir unter anderem die projekte
zur krisenbewältigung oder auch
maßnahmen zur förderung von
datenverfügbarkeit
finanzieren denn kaum etwas treibt doch
den fortschritt deshalb voran als der
permanente und stetige austausch dieses
teilen von neuen erkenntnissen und eben
auch das gemeinsame arbeiten an
gemeinsamen problemen und das ist nicht
nur national zu betrachten sondern eben
auch global und auch dieser
verantwortung werden wir uns bewusst und
sind wir uns bewusst die pandemie hat es
doch deutlich gezeigt wieder einmal dass
gesundheit nicht an eigenen
staatsgrenzen aufführen darf wir stellen
knapp
159 millionen euro für internationale
aufgaben des gesundheitswesens zur
verfügung und das sind noch einmal 13 8
millionen euro mehr als im letzten jahr
die dazu
und das finde ich bemerkenswert
deswegen möchte ich das hier nennen das
projekt der whv pandemic und apple denn
intelligenz in berlin sollten sie sich
vielleicht mal angucken wenn es denn
wenn sie zeit haben hier sorge das
unterstützen wir mit 30 millionen euro
jährlich damit begegnen wir globalen
gesundheitskrise in zukunft geschlossen
und sind auch vorbereitet
vorbereitet sind für endlich ja
und jetzt möchte ich noch eins
klarstellen an dieser stelle deutschland
steht jetzt kommt
deutschland steht übrigens an der seite
der ukraine ganz klar und deutlich wir
wissen um die menschen mit zu uns kommt
und wir wissen um die menschen mit
verletzungen sind weiten weg zu uns
geschafft haben wir wissen um die
seelischen verletzungen die diese
menschen tragen und wir werden diese
menschen unterstützen ohne wenn und aber
insgesamt ist der etat des
gesundheitsministeriums auf knapp 52 56
milliarden euro angewachsen das ist ein
zuwachs von 5 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahr eine stolze summe die den willen
dieser bundesregierung zeigt dass eben
während der pandemie die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht im stich lässt und
sicherheit garantiert liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sicherheit muss neu gedacht
werden
sicherheit im wandel ist auch ein
gesundheitssystem im wandel wir sind
bereit dafür lassen sie es uns gemeinsam
anpacken ich freue mich nun auf die
beratung es wird spannend vielen dank
svenja schulze spd fraktion und da ist
oder für die spd fraktion ist sie
mitglied im haushaltsausschuss und jetzt
gibt es einer kurzintervention sorge das
wort und hat versprochen eine sehr kurze
kurz ein wenn tradition zu machen frau
bundestagspräsidentin dass sie die große
innovation zu lassen
schade frau kollegin stadler dass sie
die zwischenfrage nicht zugelassen haben
weil ich wollte sie eigentlich loben ich
wollte ihnen danken und zwar wollte ich
ihnen danken für teile ihrer rede in der
sie ja darauf hingewiesen haben dass
digitalisierung ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt ist gerade für das zentrale system
des gesundheitssystems und deshalb meine
frage sind sie mit mir nicht auch der
meinung dass wir in der letzten
legislatur in der großen koalition also
union und spd gemeinsam auch mit dem
damaligen gesundheitsminister jens spahn
im bereich der digitalisierung viel
erreicht haben und sind sie mit mir
nicht auch der meinung dass wir
gemeinsam union und spd in der letzten
legislatur im bereich der
digitalisierung viel auf den weg
gebracht haben harris innovation hat
beispielsweise die tigers also digitale
anwendungen gesundheitswesen das ganze
thema telemedizin tele consilia
ärztliche möglichkeiten eröffnet wurde
sind also insofern herzlichen dank für
teile ihrer rede in diesem kontext und
würde mich interessieren ob sie das
genauso sehen wie ich vielen dank
frau kollegin sie können antworten sie
müssen nicht aber sie möchten
[Gelächter]
dass sie mich logan wollten finde ich ja
gut dass jetzt gerade nicht so
rausgekommen aber es ist okay ich
finde wir haben tatsächlich in der
letzten legislatur einiges auf dem weg
versucht zu bringen mit ihnen und dann
hat sich ja gezeigt wo die
schwachstellen sind und deswegen nehmen
wir diese schwachstellen jetzt natürlich
auf und werden sie in der ampelkoalition
erfolgreich umsetzen
eine kurze antwort auf eine kurze
kurzintervention war das und da sie ja
für tigges publikum sind haben sie die
systematik auch dieser debatte natürlich
längst durchschaut und ich muss ich mir
gar nichts dazu sagen denn wir haben
gegen sie haben natürlich gemerkt dass
die letzten geräten
überwiegend mitglieder des
haushaltsausschusses gewesen sind und
das ist jetzt weitergeht wieder mit den
fachpolitikern
zum thema gesundheit und
gesundheitswesen dietrich moorschlatt
aus der unionsfraktion ist der erste in
dieser reihe die
polierte politische wille hören sie
erstmal zu bevor sich beschweren der
artikulieren politische wille der
regierung mehr für eine bessere
gesundheitliche versorgung zu tun kommt
in diesem haushalt geben was nach
unserer wahrnehmung nicht zum ausdruck
auch die bisherige bilanz ist ich darf
das mal so formulieren durchaus
überschaubar mein kollege tino sorge hat
hierzu wie ich finde zutreffend
ausgeführt und frau kollegin dr
fischotter ihn rufe ich zu was hat sie
davon abgehalten in dieser koalition das
was sie hier gefordert haben auch
tatsächlich umzusetzen
darüber sollten sie mal nachdenken meine
damen und herren
bekanntermaßen liegt mir die bekämpfung
einer der größten volkskrankheiten
deutschlands diabetes mellitus und die
versorgungssituation der betroffenen
besonders am herzen gemeinsam haben wir
als union mit der spd in der letzten
legislaturperiode einen umfassenden
antrag zur einführung einer nationalen
diabetes strategie mehrheitlich hier im
bundestag beschlossen es läge nun an der
neuen regierung im sinne der über 10
millionen betroffenen die angesprochene
intensivierung der bekämpfung von
diabetes mellitus auch umzusetzen
bedauerlicherweise ist eine
weiterentwicklung und umsetzung dieser
nationalen diabetes strategie in diesem
haushalt nicht abgebildet die geplanten
ausgaben für aufklärung prävention
sollte nicht etwa erhöht werden wie man
bei begriff intensivieren meinen könnte
die ansätze der vorjahre bleiben gleich
sie werden nicht angehoben das heißt vor
dem hintergrund der aktuellen inflation
sinken die real zur verfügung stehenden
finanzmittel worte und handelns stehen
im krassen widerspruch
meine damen und herren auch bei der
erkrankung an die positiv besteht
dringender handlungsbedarf
13 prozent der kinder und jugendlichen
sind von übergewicht betroffen
acht prozent der kinder von adipositas
67 prozent der männer und 53 prozent der
frauen sind übergewichtig und 23 prozent
der männer und 24 prozent der frauen
adipös ja aus eigener betroffenheit kann
man da gut drüber reden das stimmt da
haben sie recht
übergewicht und adipositas
begünstigen viele chronische krankheiten
die dann beträchtliche kosten für die
gesundheits- und das sozialsystem
auslösen es ist daher von herausragender
bedeutung in diesem bereich präventiv zu
handeln
und ich frage sie ihre minister ganz
konkret wollen sie dass unsere kinder
immer dicker werden wollen wir dass sie
als erwachsene potenziell an diabetes
erkranken auch hier minister brauchen
wir die die in diesen tagen viel
beschworenen zeitenwende
meine damen und herren aus den oben
beschriebenen problemen folgt nach
meiner auffassung dass wir das
vergütungssystem die zahlung an die
selbstverwaltung also den sogenannten
morbi-rsa neu justieren müssen weg von
kurativen behandlungsansätzen hin zu
mehr prävention und verhaltensänderung
ziel muss sein bereits die entstehung
von vermeidbaren krankheiten zu
verhindern wesentliche
verhaltensveränderungen müssen motiviert
werden
meine damen und herren weitere wichtige
ansätze aus der letzten
legislaturperiode
werden ebenfalls nicht in der
erforderlichen intensität angegangen wie
beispielsweise das interpreten in der
endoprothesen register deutschlands ein
register dass die operation daten der
krankenhäuser sammelt und analysiert die
transformation dieses privat aufgebauten
registers in den öffentlichen bereich
droht zu scheitern
man lässt unter völliger verkennung der
ausgangssituation zu dass durch eine
mangelnde datenerfassung die
vielfältigen aussage möglichkeiten
dieses registers verloren geben auch
hier finden sie im haushalt leider keine
ansetzen
insgesamt ist sie festhalten dass diese
haushaltsentwurf keine verbesserung für
die gesundheit der menschen in
deutschland erkennen lässt ich hoffe
dass wir in den kommenden haushalt
beratung noch notwendige anpassungen
vornehmen können herzlichen dank
dietrich monstadt für die union im
gesundheitsausschuss
und für die fraktion bündnis 90
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
mit dem themenschwerpunkt gesundheit
unter anderem ist maria klein schmeink
und sie wird jetzt aufgerufen werden von
wurde es als vizepräsidentin aydan
özoguz und da ist sie schon auf dem weg
und kollegen ich finde es eigentlich
bedauerlich dass das niveau der debatte
eigentlich der größe der aufgabe nicht
wirklich gerecht wird das finde ich
wirklich bedauerlich weil wer sich mal
klarmacht wie wichtig es ist dass ich
für die großen existenziellen fragen
insbesondere die unversehrtheit des
körpers aber auch eben in der frage
gesundheit versorgung bei pflegebedarf
dass das die größten fragen sind die
eine bevölkerung umtreiben und wer
erlebt das deutlicher als diejenigen die
jetzt gerade in der ukraine erleben wie
schlimm es ist wenn genau das nicht
gewährleistet ist und das zeigt sehr
deutlich wie wichtig unsere aufgabe ist
die wir hier gemeinsam zu bearbeiten
haben das gilt für den bereich der
gesundheit das gilt für den bereich der
pflege und wir haben mit der
gesetzlichen krankenversicherungen und
mit der pflegeversicherung
wirksame instrumente um diese sicherheit
zu schaffen und auch zu finanzieren
und da ist es unsere aufgabe dafür zu
sorgen dass diese versicherungssysteme
mit dieser aufgabe auch mitwachsen
können und dem gerecht werden was der
anspruch und decke der berechtigte
anspruch der bevölkerung ist und da
reicht es nicht darauf zu verweisen man
könnte doch man sollte doch sondern wir
müssen ganz konkret liefern und leisten
und genau da haben wir große
herausforderungen vor uns wir haben 16
jahre cdu geführte union die uns eine
riesiges defizit in der gkv hinterlassen
hat wir haben eine haben 16 jahre union
geführte regierung die uns eine fast
nicht handlungsfähige soziale
pflegeversicherung hinterlassen hat und
wir haben neue aufgaben zu stemmen
einmal mit der pandemie zweitens mit der
aufnahme der vielen vielen geflüchteten
die jetzt zu uns kommen und fast alle
auch einen hohen versorgungsbedarf haben
das sind die herausforderungen die wir
zu stemmen haben und das können wir nur
gemeinsam gemeinsam mit dem
gesundheitsminister und gemeinsam hier
im parlament müssen wir dafür die
voraussetzungen
und wenn ich da sehe herr sorge wie
selbstgefällig sie hier sich hinstellen
groß etwas einklagen aber nicht einmal
im ansatz
problemlösungen geliefert haben weder
jetzt das auf scheint wie wollen sie
denn diese finanzielle probleme lösen
noch dass sie in politischer
verantwortung in der letzten wahlperiode
in der mittelfristigen finanzplanung in
ihren konzepten im wahlprogramm auch nur
eine antwort dafür geliefert hätten wie
sie diese probleme lösen wollen und das
verlange ich natürlich auch von einer
opposition wir haben das in den jahren
und wir haben viele jahre miteinander
gerungen haben das immer wieder
geliefert und ich erwarte dass auch von
ihnen
und wir haben in der ampelkoalition
einige stellschrauben verabredet wie wir
dieses geerbte defiziten lösen wollen
wir haben vereinbart dass es eine
dynamisierung des bundeszuschusses gibt
der im übrigen für versicherungsfremde
leistungen aus gekehrt wird und nicht
für die aufgaben der gkv sondern für
versicherungsfremde aufgaben sie haben
in den letzten jahren viele viele
aufgaben als es noch überschüsse gab
immer wieder in eine richtung geschoben
nämlich in die gkv und zusätzlich in die
spv dann haben wir eine große aufgabe
vereinbart dass wir die kosten der
beiträge für alle' g2 beziehende endlich
anpassen dass die beiträge ebenso
refinanziert werden dass sie auch
annähernd dem entsprechen was der umfang
der belastung für die gkv garros wird
und diese frage wird immer wichtiger
werden weil wir jetzt über 200.000
geflüchtete dazu bekommen die natürlich
nach einer gewissen zeit auch in diesen
regel kreislauf kommt dann haben wir
über haben wir vereinbart die übernahme
der rentenbeiträge für pflegende
angehörige in der spv auch das eine ganz
ganz wichtige aufgabe die da gesetzlich
und gesellschaftlich geleistet wird sie
haben dafür gesorgt dass das nur den
versicherten aufgabe über geholfen wird
und eben nicht steuerfinanziert über den
haushalt finanziert wird da haben wir
eine aufgabe die zu lösen ist weiterhin
haben wir das problem in der spv dass
die häusliche krankenpflege noch immer
nicht adäquat refinanziert wird auch das
wird etwas sein was wir zu lösen haben
wir haben also in der ampel vereinbarung
getroffen wie wir diese strukturellen
probleme lösen wir haben gleichzeitig
aber auch viele viele ansätze
verankert und vereinbart wo wir die
überfälligen antworten liefern wollen
die da sind wie große krankenhaus reform
die große reform der grundlegende
versorgung im ländlichen raum wir haben
viele viele aufgaben die wir
insbesondere auch bei der
fachkräftesicherung zu stemmen haben als
das geben wir an und dafür werden wir
auch sorgen und wir werden dafür sorgen
dass das verlässlich stabil finanziert
wird und darum werden wir in den
nächsten wochen bringen und ich hoffe
sie machen konstruktiv mit und nicht nur
mit einer billigen polemik die jede
antwort vermissen lässt
maria klein schmeink stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen der bundestag diskutiert nach wie
vor über den einzelplan 15 das ist er
für das gesundheitsministerium und da
sind einige defizite aufzuarbeiten und
hier sehen wir hier ein sonderfall von
mund nasen schutz bei christina im baum
fdp fraktion und zahnärzte
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
es ist die gesundheit die der wahre
reichtum ist nicht gold und silber
stücke das zitat ist von den massakern
die nicht erst seit corona wissen die
deutschen ihr bisher gut
funktionierendes gesundheitssystem zu
schätzen noch bis vor wenigen jahren gab
es fast in jeder größeren gemeinde einen
hausarzt einen zahnarzt eine apotheke
und in unmittelbarer nähe leicht
erreichbar auch ein krankenhaus und
fachärzte doch diese grundstrukturen
bröckelt immer mehr vor allem im
ländlichen raum der dadurch immer
unattraktiver wird viele erste nehmen
neue patienten gar nicht mehr aus weil
sie bereits überlastet sind
terminvergaben in sechs monaten oder
noch später sind keine seltenheit mehr
wie viel teurer die behandlung dadurch
werden weil sich der gesundheitszustand
der patienten bis zum sehnlichst
erwarteten termin bereits drastisch
verschlechtert hat ist nicht
verifizierbar auch nicht wie viele
patienten eventuell in der zwischenzeit
verstorben sind
verantwortlich für die inzwischen akut
gewordenen mini serien sind die
regierungen der letzten jahre denn die
probleme sind seit langem bekannt
doch auch mit der neuen regierung ist
keine besserung in sicht trotz der
unglaublichen steigerung der ausgaben
von 15,3 milliarden im jahr 2009 10 auf
über 52 milliarden in diesem jahr kein
cent davon kommt zb in der pflege an die
schlimmste entwicklung von allem jedoch
ist die profitorientierte
krankenhauspolitik durch das drg
fallpauschalensystem wurde unsere
gesundheit zur ware durch den
ökonomischen druck wird nur noch
geschaut mit welcher behandlung das
meiste geld zu verdienen ist diese
entwicklung muss gestoppt werden
gesundheitsversorgung ist
daseinsvorsorge und eines kann ich ihnen
versprechen wenn ich mit ihren banken
apparat den aktuellen haushalt durch
gehe dann finde ich genug geld um unser
gesundheitssystem wieder auf vordermann
zu bringen
eine verstümmelung unserer kinder
verharmlosend und irreführend
geschlechtsumwandlung genannt wird von
mir ebenso gestrichen wie alle ausgaben
zur gender ideologie oder den fiktiven
kampf gegen rechts der nichts weiter als
ein kampf gegen die opposition darstellt
und hören sie endlich auch ein ganzes
volk zu bevormunden
glücklichsein zufriedenheit und
lebensfreude sind die wichtigsten
voraussetzungen für unser aller
gesundheit der gesundheit beruht auf
einem gleichgewicht zwischen körper
seele und geist
nie zuvor wurde dieses gleichgewicht so
zerstört wie durch ihre corona maßnahmen
werden sie endlich die maske zusammen
mit allen maßnahmen und der enz licht in
die mülltonne denn dort gehören sie hin
vielen dank
[Applaus]
und es folgt die kollegin für die
fdp-fraktion nicole vastic und
nicole westliches pflegepolitische
sprecherin der fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen kommen wir zurück zur sache und
zur
gesundheitspolitik
als
fortschritts koalition begegnen wir den
vielfältigen herausforderungen die hier
alles schon genannt worden sind mit
einem großem verantwortungsbewusstsein
gegenüber der aktuellen und generation
und den künftigen generationen
eine große baustelle in unserem
gesundheitswesen ist die pflege und das
nicht erst seit der pandemie wenn wir
patientinnen und patienten
bedarfsgerecht versorgen wollen wenn
menschen in würde alt werden sollen dann
müssen wir hier endlich an
die pflege steht deshalb weit oben auf
der agenda dieser koalition wir wollen
die arbeitsbedingungen dort nachhaltig
verbessern das gelingt uns jedoch nur
dann wenn wir den personalmangel beheben
und mehr menschen für die pflege
gewinnen deshalb wissen wir in die
bildung in ausbildung und akademisierung
investieren gemeinsam mit den ländern
wollen wir pflegewissenschaft und
pflegeforschung voranbringen diese sind
kein selbstzweck sie geben uns
evidenzbasierte antworten auf die fragen
nach einer guten und bedarfsorientierten
patientenversorgung
und das kommt uns allen als gesellschaft
zu
eine besondere rolle spielt dabei auch
die pflege pädagogik denn zu viele
lehrerinnen und lehrer fehlen an unseren
pflegeschulen was mitunter zur
schließung führt das muss sich ganz
schnell ändern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist kommt
auf jeden ausbildungsplatz an deshalb
ermöglichen wir die pflegeausbildung
künftig auch an reha kliniken ein
weiterer baustein für mehr
pflegepersonal liegt natürlich in der
zuwanderung deshalb ist es gut dass sich
diese koalition ganz klar dazu bekennt
deutschland zu einem modernen und
weltoffenen
einwanderungsland zu machen
dass sie damit ein problem haben das
wissen wir
allerorten haben wir fachkräftemangel
aber nirgends fällt er uns so übel auf
die füße wie in der pflege mit diesem
haushalt fordern wir auch die
möglichkeit
pflegekräfte im ausland nach deutschem
standard auszubilden doch das ist nicht
genug bei der gewinnung der besten köpfe
konkurrieren wir mit ländern in denen
pflegende eine größere autonomie haben
als bei uns deshalb ist es wichtig die
halbrunde übertragung endlich umzusetzen
denn pflegen wir können mehr als sie
dürfen
und wir sind die koalition die den
menschen etwas zutraut das hat auch
etwas mit wertschätzung zu tun und diese
brauchen legen irgendwie denn je
mit mit dem community herzens schaffen
wir ein neues berufsbild
hochqualifiziert sollte die pflegerische
versorgung gerade im ländlichen raum
mitgestalten
sie hilft damit menschen auch mit
pflegebedarf länger in ihrer gewohnten
umgebung bleiben zu können und sie
stärkt pflegenden angehörigen den rücken
denn liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
filme in unserem land ist zu einem ganz
großen anteil angehörigenpflege fast ein
viertel aller pflegebedürftigen werden
zu hause von angehörigen betreut
diese menschen brauchen dringend
unterstützung
deshalb wollen wir die kurzzeit und
verhinderungspflege zu einem flexiblen
entlastungs budget zusammenfassen die
pflegegeld leistungen wollen wie
dynamisieren und mehr
kurzzeitpflegeplätze schaffen
und damit ist es nicht getan aber
wichtig ist dass wir endlich anfangen
hier entlastung zu schaffen als
fortschritts koalition wollen wir
entbürokratisieren vereinfachen
beschleunigen und vernetzen gerade im
gesundheitswesen und dabei endlich den
digitalisierungs stau in unserem land
beheben überbordende dokumentation muss
auch in konstanz
machen wir es pflegenden mit digitalen
anwendungen so einfach wie möglich
schenken wir ihnen mehr zeit nutzen wir
kalium pflegebedürftigen und pflegenden
angehörigen das leben zu erleichtern
wir stärken aber auch unsere kommunen
denn sie wissen am besten wie sie ihre
quartiere für ein gutes leben im alter
auch mit pflegebedarf gestalten wir
fördern innovative wohnformen das
pflegeheim sollte stets viele aller
letzte station sein damit das gelingt
setzen wir als ampelkoalition verstärkt
auf prävention und rehabilitation pflege
bedarf hinaus zu zögern
lebensqualität bis hin zur alter zu
ermöglichen das ist das gebot der stunde
und dafür setzen wir uns mit aller kraft
an viel ändern
nicole westlich war dass die
pflegepolitische sprecherin der
fdp-fraktion ihr wird jetzt folgen
kopien aus der fraktion die linke der
sprecher für krankenhaus und
pflegepolitik
und jetzt ermahnt
bundestags-vizepräsident
insidern böses nochmal die abgeordneten
die zeit einzuhalten sie lobt sie vor
allem dass das so gut gelungen ist
bislang unklar schau mal ob ich gucken
dass auch ihn kriegt er hat nur zwei
gewonnen die ampel einigt sich heute auf
ein entlastungspaket und sie herr
lauterbach kündigen eine erhöhung der
krankenkassenbeiträge an ist das
eigentlich schon satire herr lauterbach
ersparen hat bereits alle ersparnisse
der krankenkassen munter aufgebraucht ja
wenn wir hier nicht tätig werde im haus
dann drohen ab 20 23 spätestens 20 24
massive steigerungen für die beitrags
zahlen beiden krankenkassen aber das
bedeutet auch eine aufgabe für sie eher
lauterbach sie haben doch eine funktion
das zu verhindern sie müssen eine
ordentliche reform auf die reihe bringen
herr lauterbach das ist ihre aufgabe
das ist ein bruch der versprechen aller
koalitionsparteien die normalverdienende
nicht zusätzlich zu belasten
das werden die leute in ihrem geldbeutel
richtig spüren bei 17 milliarden euro
den kassen fehlen da geht es cirka um 1